Boom, and we're live. Hello Sir. How
are you? Nice to see you too. Thanks.
What you do eating chocolate.
When you got here and you told me that
you are a Cacau Sharmane and I said those
are strong words. They
are. What does that mean?
So I was in Berlin last year giving a
talk at a tech conference and somebody
invited me to a sacred cacao ceremony.
Never heard of it. And I thought, wow,
that sounds awesome. I love chocolate.
I went, it was so wonderful.
And at the end they were
talking about these people,
these great Cacau Schamens and I thought,
what is that? I gotta be one of those.
Since I came back,
I looked for certification.
There wasn't certification I self
declared and then I started doing a cacao
ceremonies in New York.
Now I have hundreds of people who come.
It's really wonderful and it's exciting.
Like if you want to be a doctor,
you got to go to medical school,
right? You want to be a comedian,
you got to be become a professional.
You gotta put on your time
Cacau Sham and just show up.
It's like putting up a shingle.
Hey, I'm the COUSHATTA.
And if anybody shows up and they
have a good time, then your real,
now how much do you need
to know about Krakow?
Like the nutritional properties of
a cow is amazing. It's great stuff.
It's incredible.
And so definitely cacau and people have
been using it ceremonially for about
5,000 years. Um, so it's incredible. Um,
chocolate makes people happy. It helps
your brain function, your circulation,
and there's all these
kinds of incredible things.
But in the ceremonies that I do,
I have to key messages.
One is you are the drug. I mean,
we all take people take drugs,
people take Iowa. Oscar and silicide
been all these kinds of things.
But I also think that we have for the
things that we take drugs for this kind of
release and happiness and joy,
we have those things inside of us and
we just kind of get out of our way.
We can experience them in. The second
thing is I believe that there are no,
I say this in my ceremonies.
There's no such thing as sacred
Chiuchow or sacred plants are sacred.
Mountains are sacred people.
If we don't treat life with sacredness,
but if we recognize that
everything is sacred,
then we infuse life with sacredness
and meaning and that's, anyway,
that's why I do,
it's a lot of fun.
That's very interesting from a guy who
specializes essentially in manipulating
life.
Well,
you know we have manipulated life
as humans for a very short on time,
but it's interesting the
idea of things being sacred,
but your specialty is manipulating
genetics, right? Yeah.
Well,
so that is this strange moment that
we're in because for about for about 3.8
billion years,
our species has evolved by this set of
principles we call Darwinian evolution,
random mutation and natural selection.
And it's brought us here.
We used to be single cell organisms and
now look at us and there's been a lot of
magic in that process and there still is,
but we humans are deciphering
some of that magic.
We are like looking under the hood of
what it means to be human and we are
increasingly going to have the
ability to manipulate all of life,
including our own. Yeah. That is
very unnerving to a lot of people.
It's, it's uncomfortable
and scary and yeah, it is.
They like things the way they are. We,
Amy, I'd like to stay the way I am.
We always think that there's,
we always think that there's a built in
conservative conservatism in our brains
and yet we live these lives
that are entirely dependent
on these radical changes
that our ancestors have created.
I mean,
we didn't find this building or
agriculture medicine, uh, in nature.
We built all those things and then
everybody gets a new baseline when you're
born and you think, well, you know,
I'm, I want, you know, organic corn,
I want whatever.
But all these things are creation.
We live in entirely created world and
our ability to manipulate and change that
world is always growing.
And I think we need to recognize that,
but there's being afraid is okay and
being excited as okay and we need to find
the right balance between those two
emotions. I think for a lot of people,
they feel like so many changes happen,
particularly when you're talking
about genetically modified foods.
So many things happened before
they realize they had happened.
So when they're like, hey man, I don't
want it any eat any GMO fruit. Right.
Well then you probably
shouldn't eat any fruit. Yup.
Because everything that
you buy has been changed.
Like every orange that you borrowed that,
that's why I want an orange to be like,
yeah, go buy an apple. Apple's
didn't used to be like that.
Tomatoes didn't used to be like
that. No, I know. That's we,
we reset our baseline just
from when we were kids.
So if you went back 12,000 years ago to
the end of the last ice age and you said,
all right, find me all these
things that we buy at whole foods.
Most of them didn't exist. We, we've
created them. Sure. And then in the 1970s,
we had the ability to do
what's recombinant DNA,
what people call genetic modification.
And people are afraid because
it's well that feels unnatural.
We're applying science to
food. Um, and you know, that's,
that's the issue and now we're entering
the era of genetically modified humans
and there's that same level of
uncomfortableness. But what happened,
the reason why I've written this,
uh, this book hacking Darwin,
is that if we approach genetically
modified humans in the same way,
the way we approached genetically modified
foods, which is the scientists say,
Hey, we've got this, we're going
to manage them responsibly.
And it just kind of happens to people.
People are going to go nuts. I mean,
you imagine how agitated
people are about GMO foods.
If they don't have a say in how
the genetic, the experience,
the human experience of
genetic modification plays out,
people are going to go berserk.
So we have this window of time,
we can start bringing everybody into an
inclusive conversation about where we're
going because where we are going is just
radically different from where we've
been. Yeah, I think
it's an awareness issue.
And I also think it's a perception issue.
I think that everything people
do is natural, including cities.
I think cities are natural. That's
why they're all over the world. Yeah.
I think there was naturals beehives and
I think as much as we like to think that
technology is not natural, it's clearly
something people naturally make.
Of course,
they make it in every culture they can.
It's the history of our species and we,
we kind of misused this word natural.
What is natural?
I mean,
maybe natural was when we used to
live and we were just part of nature.
And I always say it's like
people say, Oh, I love nature.
I love going out and hiking in the woods.
The reason you love hiking in the woods
is that we've murdered all the predators.
It's like in the old days,
in the year you stay in your cave,
you're not going out
and hiking in the woods.
There's stuff that's going
to kill you out there.
I know that was a massive luxury to go
wander through the forest with no weapons.
Yeah, nobody did know exactly,
but he goes, oh, I want
nature. I want my, you know,
my natural corn, I want my, my natural
Chihuahua. Even though, you know,
25,000 years ago there no
Chihuahuas, a wolves, wolves.
And look what we've done to them. I know
will look what we have done to them.
Made them pugs. Yeah. If you had natural
wheat like, or natural corn in particular,
natural corneas to be a tiny little
thing. Yeah. It's just a few, a few weeds.
Weird gross little grain.
Yup.
And then now we made it this big juicy,
sweet,
delicious thing that you put butter
on, which is great, but we can't,
we can't to have glyphosate,
glyphosate, but we can't,
we can't fetishize that.
There's some kind of imaginary world
where kind of everybody was wearing
Birkenstocks and eating a whole foods
that imaginary worlds sucked for us.
That's why we left it. It's true. But
there's some sort of a balance, right?
We know, we do appreciate the nature, uh,
aspect of our world and eagles and salmon
and all these wild things and to be
able to see them as very cool.
But yeah,
you don't want to get eaten by those
things. So you don't want them everywhere.
You want to be able to go out and get
your newspaper without being worried about
getting attacked by a
Jaguar. It helps you. Um,
when you think about the future, uh,
at least me, the one we talking about,
my concern.
Yeah.
I'm worried that rich people are going
to get ahold of this technology quick and
they're going to have massive unfair
advantages in terms of intellect,
in terms of physical
athletic ability. I mean, we,
we really can have a grossly inbounds to
world radically quickly if this happens
fast when we don't understand exactly
what the consequences of these actions
aren't until it's too late.
And then we'd try to play catch up with
rules and regulations and laws. Yeah,
that's a very, very real danger. And
that's why I've written this book.
That's why I'm out speaking
every day about this, this topic,
because we need to
recognize that if we have,
if we approach these revolutionary
technologies using the same values that we
experience today, where you know,
we're here and very comfortable,
but just down the road there
are people who are just,
who are living without many opportunities.
There are people in parts of the world
like Central African Republic where
there's just a warzone,
kids are born malnourished.
If those are our values today,
we can expect that when these
future technologies arrive,
we'll use those, those
same values. So it's real.
And right now we have an
opportunity to say, all right,
these technologies are coming. Whatever
we do, these technologies that are coming,
there's a better possible future and
a worst possible future and how can we
infuse our best values into the process
to optimize the good stuff and minimize
the bad stuff.
And certainly what you're saying is a
real risk thing of what happened when
European countries had slightly better
weapons and slightly better ships than
everybody else. They took over the world,
dominated everybody. And so yeah, that's,
it's very real.
That's the government's need to play
a role in ensuring broad access in,
in regulating these,
uh,
these technologies to make sure we don't
get to that kind of dystopian scenario
that you've laid down. Well, it's also in
terms of governments regulating things,
like why are they qualified? Who are they?
Who are the government? So just people,
right? It's the people that are either
elected or the uh, you know, or, yeah,
some sort of a monarchy or,
and you're,
you're dealing with either kings and
queens and sheikhs or you're dealing with
presidents.
And we've seen in this
country that sometimes our
presidents don't know what the
fuck they're talking about.
Right?
So who are they to disrupt science
to s to disrupt this natural flow of
technology? Well, we need side.
We need somebody to do it.
We need some representation
of our collective will be
just to avoid some of the
things like that.
Just like you just mentioned,
that that's the reason why humans
banded together and made these kind of,
the created governments.
And the reason for democracy,
especially if you have more
functioning democracies,
is that your government in some ways a
reflects the will of the people in the
government does things
that individuals can't do.
And I know there are a leather
libertarian arguments. Well,
everyone should just like if you want
a little road in front of your house,
either go build the road
and pay some somebody.
But there are a lot of things in even
in that model that won't get done.
There are a lot of kind of big national,
even global concerns that you need
some kind of, uh, of regulation.
Because what we're talking about is
the future of life and life on earth.
And there have to be
some kind of guardrails.
And that's why what I'm arguing
for is we really need a bottom up.
I think we every person,
and that's why I'm so thrilled
to be here with you today, Joe.
Every person needs to really understand
these revolutionary technologies like
genetics,
like AI and all of our responsibilities
and opportunities to say,
hey, this is really important. Here
are the values that I think that, uh,
that I cherish and just like you said,
I don't want it to be that the wealthiest
people are the ones who have kids with
higher iqs and live longer and
healthier than, than everybody else.
And then so we have to raise our voice
and our needs to be a bottom up process
and a, and a top down
process. And it's really,
it's really hard that many people have
a concern that someone else is going to
do what we're not willing to do first.
Yes, right. There were China and Russia,
those, the big ones,
China, especially China,
they're very technologically advanced
and their innovations off the chain when
it comes to lick.
Wowway just recently surpassed apple,
the number to a cell phone manufacturer
in the world. Five years ago,
they had some like a single
digit share of the marketplace.
Now they're number two on the
planet earth. I mean, they,
they hustle and if they just decided
to make super people and they,
they do it before we do. That's what
people were worried about, right?
There were who they're worried about.
There's trivial things were seemingly
trivial like athletics and then there's
things that are really clear,
like what,
what's to stop people from
just becoming the hulk?
What's to stop people from becoming
immortal? What's the style is
well live in the two
questions. First is, is China,
because I think it's a really big issue,
the 21st, the story of the 21st century,
one of the biggest stories of the 21st
century will be how the US China rivalry
plays out.
And the playing field will be with these
revolutionary technologies and China
has a national plan to lead the
world in these technologies. By 2050,
they're putting huge resources.
They have really smart people.
They are really focused on it and it's
a big deal in genetic technologies.
Um,
uh,
when last year of the book hacking dorm
was already in production in November
when it was announced that these first
genetically engineered babies had been
born in China.
And so I called the publisher and say,
we need to pull this back out of
production. So I need to reference this.
But it didn't require much of a chain
because I'd already written this is
happening. We're going to see the
world's first gene edited humans.
It's going to happen first in China.
And here's why. So I just had a, had a,
had to add a few sentences saying, and it
just happened in October of, uh, of 2018.
So China is on that path and we
need to recognize that on one hand,
the United States needs to be competitive.
On the other hand,
we don't want a runaway
arms race of the human race,
and that's why we need to find this
balance between national ambition, uh,
and some kind of of global rules.
But it's really hard to do.
Yeah. And the other thing is that
we're competing with them. Yeah.
And so if they decide to do at first
were almost compelled to do it second or
compelled to try to keep up.
Yeah.
How far away do you think we are from
physically manipulating living human
beings versus fetuses versus
think in the physically
manipulating living human
beings? We are there, so, yeah.
Yeah. So that that's, it may often, it's,
it's called gene therapy. So for example,
there's a whole class of,
of treatments for, uh,
for treating cancer called car t therapy.
So you have a cancer when you're younger,
your body is better able to fight cancers.
Um, what you can do some of the cancer,
you take their cells,
you give there,
you manipulate their cells to give them
cancer fighting superpowers and you put
them back into the person's body and now
the person's body behaves like you're a
younger person.
You have the ability to fight back.
So gene therapies are already happening.
A relatively small number of
them have already been approved,
but there is a list of thousands of
them with regulators in applications
to regulators around the world.
So that the era of gin making genetic
changes to living humans that's already
here. Like what can they
do with it? So far? So,
so far most of it is focused
on treating diseases. Um,
but a lot more is a, is coming because
when people think about the, the human,
the genome,
our genome isn't a disease genome.
It's not a healthcare genome genome.
It's a human genome.
And so we are going to be able to do
things that feel like crazy things like
changing people's eye color, changing
people's skin color to funky things.
I mean there's a lot of of room,
there weren't stuff that we're
not doing now that we will be, uh,
be able to do and anything we are
from something like that, 10 years.
So in 10 years we're going to have
green people if in, if someone,
so if someone's who chooses and if it's,
we'll be able to go back to normal car.
Well if it's, that's a good question. Um,
if it's with this kind of gene therapy
and it's a small number of genes
probably,
but we are messing with very complex
systems that we don't fully understand it.
So that's why there's a lot of unknowns.
And coming back to your point
on regulation, that's why we,
I don't think we want a total
free for all. We're feels, hey,
I'm going to edit my own jeans.
You don't want some backyard hustler.
Yeah, it's true lab. It's
true. Cause they, you were
saying about the hulk. I mean,
I just think that there are all kinds of,
you know, we're humans, we're diverse.
Any kind of thing that you can think of.
There is a range and there's, you know,
crazy on the left and crazy on
the ride and crazy at the top.
And so people are going to want
to do things. And the question is,
if for any society,
what do we think is okay and
what do we think is not okay?
And maybe there should be some,
I believe there should be some
limit to how far people can go with
experimenting, certainly,
possibly likely on themselves,
certainly on their future children.
Certainly on the future children. Yeah.
But once you're 18, I think, do whatever
the fuck you want. If you really,
well maybe 25,
25,
we're going to have a lot of 25
year olds with Gills. It's like,
it's like the tattoo seemed like a good
idea. Yeah. Well we probably will. Um,
so you think we're probably like 50
years away from that being a reality.
So I think that we are,
we,
the genetic revolution has already begun
and it's going to fundamentally change
our lives in in three big areas.
The first is our healthcare,
so we're moving from a system of
generalized healthcare based on population
averages so that when
you go to your doctor,
you're treated because you're a human
just based on average and we're moving to
a world of personalized medicine and the
foundation of your personalized health
care will be your sequence genome
in your electronic health records.
That's how they know you are you and
that's what they can say, this is a drug,
this is an intervention that will
work for you. When we do that,
then we're going to have
to sequence everybody.
So we're going to have about 2 billion
people have had their whole genome
sequenced,
a within a within a decade,
and then we're going to be able to compare
what the genes say to how those are
expressed and then
humans become a big data set and that's
going to move us from precision to
predictive healthcare where you're going
to be just born and you're going to
have all this information or your parents
have all this stuff about how certain
really important aspects of
your life are going to play on.
Some of that is going
to be disease-related,
but some of that's going
to be life related.
Like you have a better than average
chance of being really great at math or
having a high Iq,
low Iq or being a great sprinter
and how do we think about that?
And then again,
a revolution that's already happening,
we're going is going to
change the way we make babies.
We're going to get away from sex as
the primary mechanism for conceiving.
Our kids will still have sex
for all the great reasons we do.
And that's going to open up a
whole new world of a gist of how,
of applying science to what it means
to be a human with a lot of new
possibilities.
That's what's going to be so freaky when
people stop having sex to my kids and
they make friends in the lab. Every
kid's made in the lab when not only that,
I think we're going to move to an era,
an era where people who have,
who make babies through sex
will be seen as taking a risk,
kind of like people who don't vaccinate
their kids where it's natural.
Tonight it's more natural to not
vaccinate your kids then to do it,
but people say, wait a second, you're
taking on a risk on behalf of your kids.
About 3% of all kids in the world are
born with some kind of harmful genetic
abnormality using in vitro
fertilization and embryo screening.
That 3% can be brought down significantly
and what happens if you see somebody
20 years from now who has a kid with
one of those preventable diseases?
Do you think that's fate already? Think
well on, wait a second. Those parents,
they made an ideological decision about
how they want it to conceive their kids.
So I think we're moving towards some
really deep and fundamental changes. Hmm.
Well, yeah, that's,
that's an interesting
conversation of whether or not
you wonder what if we're ever going to
get to a point where people don't allow
people sort of like, people don't allow
people to not get vaccinated. Right.
And like there's a lot of
that going on today, right?
Which is great, right? You don't
want diseases floating around.
But what if that gets to the place
where we do that with people,
with people creating new life
forms? What have you say, hey,
you aren't being irresponsible. You're
just having sex and having a kid. Yeah,
I know that's your grandma did it. We
don't do it that way in 2099. Yeah.
I think it's going to be hard to do that
in a society like the United States,
but in a country like North Korea, they'll
be able to do that. Or if a country,
if they said, look, um, you can
make babies however you want,
but if you make babies the old fashioned
way and if you have some kind of
genetic you, your kid has some kind of
genetic disorder that was preventable,
we're just not going to
cover it with insurance.
So you're going to have a
$10 million lifetime bill.
You don't need to,
you don't need to require something.
You can create an environment where
people's behaviors will change.
And then there, there will be increasing
social pressures. I mean, right now,
you know,
somebody sees some little kid riding
around their bicycle without a helmet.
They're kind of looking at the
parents like, Hey, what are you doing?
How come you're, you're, you
don't have a helmet on your kids.
And I just think that we're moving
toward this kind of societal change where
people will, I believe, see, uh,
conceiving their kids in the lab
as a safer, safer alternative.
And it's not just safety.
Because once you do that,
then that opens you up to the
possibility of all other kinds of,
of applications of,
of technology.
Not just not just to eliminate
risks or prevent disease,
but you have a lot more information.
So already it's possible to,
to roughly rank order 15
preimplantation embryos,
tallest to shortest in a
decade from highest a genetic
component of Iq to lowest
genetic component of Iq. I mean this
stuff is very real and it's very personal.
What do you think will be the first
thing that people start manipulating?
I think certainly health health is,
will be the primary driver because that's
every parents biggest fear and that's,
that is what is going to be
kind of the entry application.
People wanting to make sure that their
kids don't suffer from terrible genetic
diseases. And then I think the
second will probably be longevity.
Me Right now there's a lot of work going,
uh,
they're going on sequencing people,
the super agers people who live to their
late nineties people do a hundred to
identify what are the genetic
patterns that these people have.
So it's like to live to 90, you have
to do all the things that you advocate,
healthy living and whatever.
But to live to into a hundred,
you really need the genetics
to make that possible.
So we're going to identify what are some
of the genetic patterns that allow you
to live those kinds of, of long
lines. But then after that,
then it's wide open. I mean it's,
it's higher genetic component of Iq,
outgoing personality, faster
sprinter. I mean we are humans,
we are primarily genetic beings and
we're going to be able to look under the
hood of what it means to be human and
we'll have these incredible choices. And,
and we have,
it's a huge responsibility.
How long do you think before
we have a person with forearms?
I think it's going to take a long time.
Couple hundred years. Well, the thing is,
here's how I see it. So the real driver,
there's two, two primary drivers.
One will be embryo
selection. Um, so right now,
average woman going through IVF
has about 15 eggs extracted. Um,
and then in IVF,
in vitro fertilization,
those eggs are fertilized using the male
sperm and an average male ejaculation,
there's about a billion sperms. So, so
men are just given it away. Women now,
human female mammals are a little bit,
or a little bit stingy,
but then the next killer application
is using a process called induced
pluripotent stem cells.
And so Shinya Yamanaka these
great a Japanese scientist
won the 2012 Nobel prize
for developing a way to turn
any adult cell into a stem cell.
So a stem cells are kind of cell, it
can be anything. Um, and so you take,
let's say a skin graft
that has millions of cells.
You induce those,
those adult skin cells into stem cells.
You use these four things called
Yamanaka factors. And so now you have,
let's call it a hundred
thousand stem cells,
and then you can induce those cells
into egg precursor cells and then eggs.
So all of a sudden humans are creating
eggs like salmon on this huge scale.
So you have 100,000 eggs,
fertilize them with the male sperm
in a machine and automated process.
You grow them for about five days and
then you sequence cells extracted from
each one of those.
And the cost of genome sequencing in
2003 it was $1 billion and now it's $800
it's going to be next to
nothing within a decade.
And then you have real options cause then
you get this of this whole spreadsheet
and algorithm and then you
go to the parents. They will,
what are your priorities?
And maybe they'll say, well I want
health, I want longevity, I want high Iq.
When you're choosing from big numbers
like that, you have some real options.
And then on top of that,
then there is this precision gene
editing the stuff that happened in,
in China last year.
And I think it will,
it will be in the re coming back
to your question about forearms,
I think it's going to be varied.
People have this idea that
tools like CRISPR going abused,
someone's going to sit at a computer and
say like forearms and three heads and
wings and whatever. But it's
pretty hard because, um,
human biology is incredibly complicated
and we, we, we always know more,
um,
the worth,
the very beginning of understanding the
full complexity of human biology enough
to make these big kind of changes.
But if you're choosing from
100,000 fertilized eggs,
those are all your natural kids.
Yeah.
And then you would get the best of
that and then work on those. Exactly.
And that's exactly the amount. And you
get that. And then you say, all right,
what if you had like 20 sons that were
awesome and they didn't tell you about 18
of them and you kept two of them than
18 of them shipped off to some military
industrial complex. Yeah.
Turned them into assassins.
Any kind of crazy thing you can
think of. That's the problem, right?
It's all this stuff will be possible.
And so, and a lot of technologies,
you can imagine all kinds of crazy stuff.
And that's coming back to your earlier
point about regulation is we want to live
in regulated environments.
I mean,
so like now think of the Internet and heal
in the beginning days of the Internet.
People Thought, oh, just let the Internet
be let you know, just let it play out.
It's going to liberate all of us.
And now China's showing how the Internet
can be actually be really actively used
to suppress people.
Facebook is,
is taking people's information in
Google in a way that's frightening.
A lot of people and peers are saying,
hey,
it shouldn't be that these
companies can do whatever they want.
We have to have some way of establishing
limits because not every individual is
able to entirely protect themselves.
They don't have the power,
they don't have all the information.
We need some representatives helping us
with the real concern is the competition.
Right? The real concern is whether or not
we do something with reg in regards to
regulation.
That's somehow another stifles competition
on our end and doesn't allow us to
compete with Russia and
China, particularly China.
Yeah, that's exactly right.
And so, um, what we need to
do is to find that balance.
And one of the big issues,
uh, for this is privacy.
So if you kind of look around the world,
I'd say there's of the,
of the kind of the big countries
in groupings of countries,
there's three models of privacy.
There's Europe,
which has the strongest privacy
protections for all kinds of data,
including genetic,
did a data.
There's China that has the weakest and
there's the United States that has the
middle. And the paradox is
from an individual perspective,
we are all are thinking,
well we kind of want to be like Europe
because I don't want somebody accessing
my personal information,
especially my genetic information.
This is like my most intimate information.
But genetics is the
ultimate big data problem.
And so you need these big data pools
and you'd access to the these big data
pools in order to unlock
the secrets of genetics.
So these three different groupings,
everyone's making a huge bet on the
future and the way we're going to know who
wins.
Like right now in the,
in the it world we have Amazon and apple
and Google and those big companies,
but whoever gets this bet,
right?
They will be the ones who will be leading
the way and making a huge amount of of
money on these technologies
because we were talking about is,
is trillion multi-trillion
dollar industry.
How do you think this is going to affect
things like competitive athletics?
Hugely. So, um, right now,
um, we have this problem,
someone like Lance Armstrong cause he
was doing, he's manipulating his, uh,
his body and what he's basically doing
is adding more red blood cells so that he
can carry more oxygen and people feel
that that's cheating. And it's a,
it's a different topic that probably
everybody in the Tour de France was doing
exactly that when he, when
he went. Um, but what if it,
which will be the case,
we're going to be able to sequence the
people would say nobody's doing drugs and
we sequence all these athletes,
some of them will just have
a natural genetic advantage.
Their bodies will naturally be doing
what Lamstar Lance Armstrong had
manipulated his body to. Do
you know, that's happening
with a sprinter right now?
Yeah. Well that females prints this has
high levels of testosterone. Yeah. No.
And it's, and I feel really sorry for
her, but we have categories. I mean, yeah,
you with your world and
in mixed martial arts,
I mean I think I remembered in the
past there was some person who has,
who was kind of a borderline,
uh,
between genders and was just kicking the
shit out of all of these women in cage
fighting.
It's like we have these categories of
man and woman and we know that the gender
identities are,
are fluid.
But how do we think about it when these
genetic differences confer advantages?
So if your body is primed to do something,
um,
maybe you could have like a Plato's
republic world where everybody fulfills a
function that you are
genetically optimized to and
that you could imagine that
being a very competitive kind of a,
of environment.
But what do you do if for now
in something like the Olympics,
if somebody has this
huge genetic advantage,
should we let somebody else
manipulate their bodies?
There's this thing called gene doping in
order to change the expression of genes,
so your body to act like
you're as Jeanette naturally
genetic enhances somebody
else.
It's complicated.
Are they capable of doing certain
physical enhancements through gene doping
right now? Like what can they
do right now known as? So,
so the way it works is so your,
your genes instruct your cells
to make proteins. That's, that's,
that's how the whole system works.
So you can change genes or you can trigger
the expression of proteins so you can
get people's bodies to
behave as if they had the,
these periodic optimization. Yeah.
Yeah. And so that's why now the,
the world antidoping agency,
I mean,
they are now starting to look
at gene doping and this is
the first time, uh, that,
that's, that that's even being
considered as a category.
And then there are other people that
have done that or other people that have
done that successfully. You know,
I don't know the answer to that.
I know that water is looking for it,
which makes me assume that it must
have done, but I haven't seen it.
I've looked for it. I haven't
seen any reports. Kind of
starts winning everything,
which know is so, so my, my, I wrote
my, uh, one of my Psi Phi novels.
Genesis code was about this.
So China as you know,
has their system of their
Olympic sports goals.
And the way it works is they
test kids all around the country.
So let's just say it's,
it's diving and they identify what
are the core skills of a diver,
what do you need?
And then they go around the country and
they test kids and then they bring a
bunch of them to the Olympic sports
schools, uh, and then they, you know,
they get them all involved and then some
kids are the best of those kids and the
best of those kids. And then you get with
these champs, that's why China advanced.
So, uh, so rapidly. But what
happens if they're doing that?
But it's at the genetic level and there
are countries like Kazakhstan that are
already announcing that they are going
to be screening all of their athletes so
that the science isn't there yet.
So it's really,
it's impossible right now to say,
well,
I'm going to do a genome sequence of
somebody and I know this person has the
potential to be an Olympic sprinter,
but 10 years from now that's
not going to be the case.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's sort of going to throw a monkey
wrench into the whole idea of what is fair
when it comes to athletics. Yeah. What is
fair? What is human? What is human? Yeah.
I mean,
look,
it's not like people don't already
alter their bodies by training,
by diet, exercise, all sorts of
different recovery modalities,
cryotherapy, song, uh,
all of it. Um, you know,
a high elevation training,
all these different things that they
do that manipulates the human body,
but it's not like it would be kind of
crazy if you had sports but you couldn't
practice and he couldn't work out.
Like we want to find out what a
person's really like. No practice,
no working out. And that's the thing.
It's like we are moving, it comes back to,
we were saying before about nature.
It's like we have this,
this feeling nature somehow
feels comfortable to us.
That's what we're used to with all
this stuff that you're talking about.
But nobody was doing that 10,000 years
ago. It's like, Hey, I'm, you know, I'm,
I'm running after a buffalo and,
and so and so as these boundaries change
as the realm of possibility changes,
then we're going to be faced
with all of these questions.
Even now look at a sport like
competitive weightlifting.
I know they have these like the,
the real competitive bodybuilding
and you see these guys and they're,
they're monsters and then they have
these drug free guys and everybody looks
like a Yogi.
And then it looks still a pretty big,
pretty big but not compared to these,
these other guys.
The only way to get those freak levels,
it's just a romance.
And so like how are we
going to police this?
And I think it's going
to be very difficult.
And so maybe we can have some
kind of natural area of life,
but I think that our, our model of
what's normal is just going to change.
Cause,
like I was saying in the beginning,
we set our baseline based on how we
grew up and that it seems about right,
like it seems about right to us
that everybody gets immunizations.
But immunizations are a form of
superpower. Imagine if our ancestors,
they couldn't even imagine immunizations.
What an unfair advantage when you
have 100 million people dying of,
of Spanish flu.
So we're with this,
all this stuff is scary and
it's going to normalize.
But how it normalizes is,
is that's what's it playing now?
Well the world has changed so
much just in the last 20 years,
but it feels like this is just scratching
the surface in comparison to what's
coming.
It was a,
people miss understand and they
underestimate the rate of change.
And the reason that they do that is
since the beginning of the digital
revolution,
we have experienced the thing called
exponential changes that you've heard of
Moore's law, which is basically computing
power roughly doubles every two years.
And we've internalized Moore's law.
And that means that every new iPhone
we expect to be better and stronger and
faster and all these kinds of things.
But now we're entering in a world,
a world where we're going to have
exponential change across technology
platforms.
And so we think about,
well what does exponential change
mean in the context of biology? Well,
at the very,
very beginning it's genome sequencing is
is is going to be basically a basically
free,
but we're going to be able to change life.
And because we're on this j curve,
like when you think of what's a 10 year
unit of change looking in the in the
rear view mirror,
that amount of change is only going to
take five years going forward and then
two years and then one year.
And so that's the reason why
I've written this book as I,
as we have to get that this
stuff is coming fast and if
we want to be part of it,
we have to understand it and we
have to make our voices heard.
What makes you nervous about
this? Alright, three big areas.
First humans and all advice.
Incredibly complex.
May We talk about genetic code,
which is mindbogglingly complex,
but our genetics exists
within the incredible,
incredibly complex systems biology. We
have all these things like our microbiome,
our virome are proteome are metabolome
and then that exists within the context
of our environment and everything's
always changing and, and interacting.
And so we are messing and we have the
tools to mess and we will mess because
we're this hubristic species with
these really complex ecosystems,
including ourselves. We don't fully
understand. That's number one. Two,
when you mentioned it before, this issue
of, of equity, what happens if we have,
every technology has to have first
adopters. If you don't have it,
you never get the technology.
But what happens if a group of people
move much more quickly than other people,
whether it's real or not, even if they
believe it's real. You could imagine big,
dangerous societal changes.
And the third big area is diversity.
And we think about diversity.
We think why it's great to have diverse
workplaces and schools and and we're
more better people for it
and we're more competitive.
The diversity is something much,
much, much deeper. In Darwinian terms,
diversity is random mutation.
Like that's our core survival strategy
as a species. If we didn't have that,
you could say we distilled be single
cell organisms, but we wouldn't,
we would have died because the environment
would have changed and we wouldn't
have had the builtin
resilience to a doubt. Yeah.
That is really important when you
think about diversity, right? Yeah.
We need a non uniformity when it
comes to our own biology. Yeah.
Because he'd a bunch of different kinds
of people. We have to have it big as,
even if we optimize for this
world, um, the world will change.
There's no good and bad in evolution.
There's just well suited for
a particular environment.
If that environment changes the best
suited person for your old environment,
maybe the least suited
person for the new insurance.
So even if we have things that seem real,
like really great ideas now,
like optimizing health.
So if you have sickle cell disease,
you're probably going to die and you're
going to die young and it's going to be
excruciating, excruciatingly
painful. And so he would say, well,
let's just get rid of sickle cell disease,
which we can do.
But if you are a recessive carrier of the
[inaudible] of the sickle cell disease
gene, you don't have it.
You're just carrying it.
You have a pretty significant risk
of passing it on to your kids,
but you also have an additional
resistance to malaria.
And so we are probably are almost
certainly carrying around all kinds of
recessive traits, maybe even ones that we
don't like that are harming us now. Um,
but that could be some protection against
some future danger that we don't yet
understand or how or haven't faced.
And so the challenge is that diversity
has just happened to us for 4 billion
years now we're going to have
to choose it. And that's a big,
it's a big challenge for us.
So essentially we were going to have,
without some
unintended consequences,
some unintended domino effect,
things that are going to take
place that we really can't predict.
We just have to kind of go along with
this technology and see where it leads us
as it improves.
Like if you go back and look at surgeries
from the 1950s comparison to surgery
of 2019 giant leaps.
I mean,
I would never advise someone to get
their knee operated by a 1950s physician.
Right, right. Yeah. Right.
But that's kind of someone's going to
have to be an early adopter when it comes
to these genetic therapies.
Yeah, no. So I, I agree with you,
but where I would slightly agree,
I would add to what you're saying is these
technologies, they're going to happen,
they're going to play out what's at play
now is not where these technologies are
going to advance. They will, it will do,
they will advance in a way that is
going to just blow people's minds.
What's it play is what are the values
that we are going to weave in to the
decision making process so that we can
get a better outcome than we otherwise
would have had. And that that's
what, in my view, that's the real,
the important issue now.
Yeah.
Unintended consequences are something
that I've been taken very seriously lately
when I'm paying attention
to technology as a,
as it's used in social media,
particularly. Uh, the one,
one of the things is disturbed me quite
a bit over the last few weeks is that
there's a model that they
use and not intentionally,
but there's a model that they use to
get people upset about things. Yeah.
Show you things in your feed that you
argue against because that makes you click
on the more and engage in them more.
And because of the fact that we have
this advertiser based model where people
were trying to get clicks because they
want to get ads on their page and the
more clicks they get,
the more money they get from those ads.
And so they want to
incentivize people to go there.
And the best way through
the algorithm would,
what they've found without doing it
on purpose is to get people upset and
they're pushing people into these little
information ghettos that are really
dangerous.
Right.
And we've gotten to this point where this
is just an accepted part of our lives.
Did you go to check your Google feed
or your Facebook feed and the, Oh boy,
what the fuck are they doing?
Is this real? They're going
to pass this, God dammit.
And then he'd get mad and then you engage
with people online and then it results
in more revenue.
But getting them to stop that,
if you had to go to Facebook and say,
hey,
hey mark Zuckerberg or now you have
fucking $100 billion, whatever you got,
but you can't make any
more money this way. Right.
Because what you're doing
is fucking up society.
Cause you're encouraging dissent,
you're encouraging people to be upset and
arguments and you're doing it at great
financial reward but great societal
costs. Yeah. So stop. Yeah.
And he's so do it. Right.
Well he may not do it.
That comes back to the point about
regulation and the question is how big is
your stick? And one of the guys who
was the founder of [inaudible] is yes,
is now coming out and saying, hey,
Facebook needs to be broken up.
And then he was one of the
original founders and he's like,
it has gotten so far out of hand.
It's so far away from where it is.
It's literally affecting global politics.
Yeah.
Well it is.
And so one option is to break it up
that it seems to have worked pretty well
with at and T. Um, another option
is to regulate it, which I is,
act in my mind would be a better approach.
And that is to say,
here's what's okay and
here's what's not okay.
And this stuff is really intricate.
You have to really get down
beneath these algorithms,
which are unbelievably complex.
But you're exactly right. I mean,
what we're seeing now is we are being
pushed into it. I said inflammation,
ghettos, but it's like
information barricades and
so pushed into camps. And so,
and it's so dangerous because the old,
I mean this,
this country is based on
not everybody agreeing,
but having a process where people come
and they work it out and they say,
you know,
I'm not perfectly happy with this outcome,
but here's a compromise and if we can't
compromise and our civic culture is
going to break down and there's so much,
I mean,
people don't see these pillars
that are holding up our society.
I'd lived in Cambodia for two years and
if you don't have these civic pillars
under your society, society's
look very, very different.
Everyone's life experiences.
V We kind of take for granted.
You can go out the door,
walk to Starbucks and not get
shot or a you can have your house.
Something happened,
your house gets robbed.
You called the police and
the police aren't the ones
who've robbed your house or
they're not in. I mean there's
all these kinds of crazy things.
If we break down the foundations
that underpin our lives,
that's really dangerous.
What I was kind of getting at
was that through what this,
this process of this algorithm, how this
algorithm selects things for the you,
your feed and how people are getting
upset by this and how this is generating
massive amounts of revenue
once it's already happened.
It's very difficult to stop and my concern
would be that this would be a similar
thing when it comes to genetic
engineering. What we're saying,
we need to be able to
put regulations on this.
We needed to be able to establish it.
But once it gets out of the bag,
once it gets rolling,
and I have,
you remember when Mark Zuckerberg sat
in front of all those politicians,
they had no fucking idea what they were
talking about. You make money as such,
Piss, poor prepares, and it just,
it shows you like these are the
people that are looking out for us.
Good fucking luck. These are Luddites.
They're dumb asses. They're fools, right?
And they're, they don't know anything
about us. Some are better and worse,
but yet almost everyone was underwhelming
and under impressive in that hearing,
in that hearing.
Yeah.
The fact that they're dealing with one of
the most important moments of our time,
but they didn't bring on some sort of
a like legitimate technology expert who
could explain it. Pitfalls. Yes.
And do so in a way that the,
the rest of the world's can,
you know,
so they're not going to protect us
from genetic engineering either. Right.
Because they're great generalists in terms
of their education for the most part.
And they're not, they're
not concerned. This is not,
they're concerned with raising
money for their campaign.
The concern with getting reelected.
That's their concern with,
yeah,
I totally agree with you that if we wait
to focus on this issue until it becomes
a crisis,
it's going to be too late because all
the big decisions will have been made.
The reason why I wrote this book,
the reason why, you know, I'm on my,
it's almost week three of this book
tour doing events like this every day is
what I am saying in every form that
I can is this is really important.
You kind of,
we were watching the news yesterday,
they had this royal baby in in the UK.
Like I don't give a shit.
It doesn't affect my life in any but,
but what does it play now is the future
of our entire species and our democracy
and our lives and we have to be focusing
on those things because we have a
moment now where we can it to a certain
extent influence how these revolutions
play out.
And if we just wait around,
if we're distracted and we're focusing
on all this stuff that's sucking up our
attention and whether it's Trump or Brexit
or molar and all these things, I mean,
we're spent how much of our time
are we spending focus on this? Fine,
let's pay a little bit of attention,
but there's really big stuff 50
years from now, a hundred years,
and no one's going to look back and
now say, oh, that was the age of Trump,
or that was,
they're going to say that was the age
when after almost 4 billion years of
evolution,
humans took control of their
own evolutionary process
and it's huge and it's
going to change all of life and of what
I'm trying to do is to say everybody has
to have a seat at the table.
Whether you're a conservative Christian,
whether you're a
biohacking transhumanists,
everybody needs to be at the table because
we are talking about is the future of
our species. We're talking
about the future of our species,
but are we even capable of understanding
the consequences of these actions to
the stuff that we're discussing?
Like right now,
I'm not like I'm talking about
it. If someone said, hey,
you've got to go speak in front of people
about the consequences of an a very
clear one hour presentation,
I'd be like, no, I'm not. Well,
what I'm talking about one, we can go
together. So you're good. Thank you. Um,
but to the reason why I've written this
book hacking Darwin is I wanted to say
if you could read just one book,
and it's written just for everybody in a
very clear way with a lot of jokes that
I think are funny. My mother laughed
at them as well, that you get it.
And then once you know, just the
basics as a human being, anybody,
it has an equal right to be part of this,
of this conversation as
the top scientist or the,
the leaders of any of any countries
that they would agree with you there.
But I don't think that other people
are going to see it that way.
I think the people that are in
control, they're not going to say, hey,
we need to find it. We need
to be fair with everyone.
All the citizens, the world.
How do you feel we should proceed?
No, but that's why we have to,
that's why we need this
bottom up ground swell.
But we can't have a bottom
up ground swell if people,
if just general people aren't even
aware of what the issues are and that's,
that's the challenge. And
that's why forums like yours
or are just so important.
I mean, you have all of these
people and then you know,
maybe everyone doesn't listen to this
podcast. Say, all right, I get it.
I can go give that hour long speech.
But you can read a couple books and then
you can give an an hour speech because
the issues like, yes, there
are scientific issues,
but this isn't a
conversation about science.
This is about values and
ethics and our future.
And it has to be a conversation
for everybody. Yeah.
It's not just a scientific conversation.
It's a conversation about the future
of the species and the species will be
awesome. Yeah. And that's something
we're wholly unqualified. No, it's you,
but here's, here's a little
vote for optimism. Okay.
We have never been this
literate as a species room.
We've never been this educated.
I don't think it was or if we ever
been this nice either. Well I hope so.
I really do.
When you look at it,
all the wars and all the murder that
used to happen, it's actually a,
this is the best time ever to be alive.
Still Sucks for people
that are in bad situations,
but it's on average it's better. And we've
never been this connected. So we have,
so I,
I'm the book I call for a species wide
dialogue on the future of human genetic
engineering. You think of one that's
nuts. 7 billion people on Earth.
How are they going to,
how are they going to do that?
But we have the opportunity and we
have to try because you don't want,
like with the beginning of the
genetically modified crops era,
the scientists were
actually really responsible,
but regular people weren't consulted and
they felt that these guys just did it
to me. So if you have all the marchers
with genetically modified organisms,
we are entering the era of genetically
modified humans and that's going to scare
the shit out of people.
And so we need to start preparing and
we need to make people feel that they're
respected and included and our government
leaders aren't going to do it for us.
So we have to find ways
of engaging ourselves.
And that's why with me with the book, I
set up a website where people can, um,
can share their views,
debate with other people.
I really want everybody to
be part of this conversation.
How do you think it's going to
play out in terms of how people,
various religions perceive this?
Yeah, so there's a real variation.
So there are people on one end of the
spectrum who believe that this is quote
unquote playing God.
And if you believe that the world was
created exactly as it is by some kind of,
uh, of divine force, um,
and that it's wrong for
humans to change to,
to quote unquote play God,
it's hard to explain how you could
justify everything that we've done.
I mean we've changed the face of this,
uh, of life on this planet earth.
But I really respect people who say,
look, I think that there's a line that,
you know,
the,
I believe that life begins at conception
and that any kind of manipulation after
conception is interfering. That's
going too far. And I respect that. Um,
and those people need to
have a seat at the table. Um,
and that's in there certainly very
strong religious views in Judaism.
There's an idea called Tikun Olam,
which means that the world is created,
cracked and broken, and it's
the responsibility of each
person to try to fix it.
And that's a justification
for using science and doing
things to try to make the
world a better place. And then there
are now these new kind of, I mean,
transhumanism, it's almost like a
religion. It's this religion of science.
And so
we're going to have, we're
humans, we're so diverse.
We are going to have
this level of diversity.
And the challenge is how do we make,
how do we have a process that brings,
brings everybody in. But it's, it's tough.
So when we're talking about genetic,
any sort of genetic manipulation,
we're basically talking about
doing stuff to the wet ware,
doing stuff to the biology.
Right.
What do you think about symbiotic
interactions with technology?
Because one of the things that I'm
concerned with more than anything is this
sort of inevitable path of
technology getting into our bodies,
whether it's through nanobots fixed
diseases or through implementation.
When we were talking yesterday
about chips, right? Like what would,
what would they have to do to get you
to get up, put a chip in your body?
Like what, what kind of powers would it
have to have before you accepted it? Yeah.
Well, people already doing
it in Sweden. Yeah, sure.
And so are they doing in
Sweden? Yeah, they're just,
they're putting this little chips in
their hands in there and under their skin
and they're using it to open doors and
access things. Um, so it's just starting.
So I definitely believe the,
you know, right now you look at,
we look at photographs of
our parents and you like God,
look at your hair or your clothes. That's
crazy. Definitely. I think that, you know,
20 years from now,
30 years from now,
people are going to look at
pictures of us and you say,
what's that little rectangular thing?
And you're going to say that was a phone
what? And they'll say what it's like,
yeah we used to carry it around in
our pocket and like Michael Douglas,
when you watch him in that movie Wall
Street, he's got that giant phone.
The beach. Exactly. So we are, we are all,
we are all Michael Douglas
because our technology,
you're absolute right is not going
to be something that we carry around.
It's technology is coming
inside of our bodies.
That is the future of where it's going.
And you know, people say, well what,
what is human genetic engineering have
to do when we know that AI is going to
get more and more powerful. But the future
of technology feature of all of this,
it's not human or AI,
it's human plus Ai.
And that is what's going to drive our,
we are co evolving with our technology
and that's what's going to drive our
drive us forward. But you're exactly
right to be afraid. And to be concerned.
And again, everything has a little,
how are we going to regulate it?
What are we going to have guard rails of,
how far is too far?
We going to let companies
just do whatever they want.
Are we going to put restrictions
on what they can do?
I think letting the whole
world decide though, you're,
you're gonna run into those religious
roadblocks if for sure. And that's,
and that's the challenge, is that the
science is advancing exponentially.
Whatever we do.
And so we have to have our understanding
of the science needs to at least try to
keep pace regulations need to keep up on
part of the World Health Organization,
International Advisory Committee
on human genome editing.
So we're meeting six
times this year in Geneva.
And the question that we're asking is
how do we think about global regulation,
at least to try to put limits on
the far ends of what's possible.
And it's, it's really, really difficult.
But that's why we need to
have this kind of process.
And it seems impossibly ambitious,
but every crazy idea,
it has to begin somewhere. So you're
doing every couple months. Yeah. Yes.
Wow. Yeah. Cause they'd want to
be on top of it as things change.
Well that's the goal. It's just, it's
so hard because almost impossible.
It's impossible and simple.
So I said that's why even the
World Health Organization,
which is the lead Health
Organization of the United Nations,
it's not enough if the
task is so much bigger.
And that's why we need to have this kind
of gripped bottom of groundswell that
I'm pushing for. And you're absolutely
right when he said before, like,
because there's not a crisis,
people are focusing on other things.
Open any news site,
like what do you see?
It's not like the really
important stuff. It's, you know,
Trump did this or Kardashians did that.
And like we're in this culture where
there are a lot of draws on our attention,
but sometimes there's really important
stuff and people are afraid of it.
People are afraid of science.
People feel like,
I remember science from high school. I
didn't like it. I was uncomfortable. Um,
you know, this is, this is for technical
people and I just feel like we can't,
science is so deeply
transforming the world.
Not just around us but within us.
And so we have to understand it and
people who are explaining science like me,
the onus is on us.
Like if somebody reads my book and says,
well that was really dense,
that was too hard.
Like that's my failure. Like I was
giving a talk in New York a couple of,
a couple of weeks ago and so I gave my
my talk and I try to make this really
accessible for people. People
were all jazzed up, they got it.
And then there was this wonderful guys,
brilliant senior scientist at this myth,
this major stem cell research
center. And so the, the,
the host said, all right, Jamie
just talked, um, can you sign it?
Can you give us a little background on
the science? This guy knows so much.
And he started going and it was very
technical and you could just like get to
see the faces of the people in
the audience. He was like, Oh God,
what's happening here?
And just like their level of excitement,
it's just shrunk because
it couldn't really cook.
And scientists,
scientists aren't trained
by and large to communicate.
And to see in the fisheries.
So a little more than a month ago,
I was in Kyoto in Japan and I went to
the laboratory of the world's leading
scientists who's doing a process of what
I mentioned earlier of turning adult
cells into stem cells into eggs.
And so this,
this will revolutionize the way
humans reproduce. And so I had,
it was in a meeting, um, with
his, uh, top postdoc students.
So these are like really the
cutting edge of these technologies.
And I went around to each of them
and I said, here's my question.
I have two questions for each of you.
One,
tell me what you're doing now and to
tell me what are the implications of what
you're doing now for 50 years from now.
And the furniture,
the first question goes,
oh,
I'm doing this and we're
doing this with mouse models.
And people were so animated. And
then 50 from now, people just froze.
And it was so uncomfortably.
They were like squeezing the table just
because that's not what scientists do.
They're trained to say, well, this
is the thing just in front of me.
So I thought I was writing this
book for the general public,
but I'm being invited to
speak to thousands of doctors
and scientists because
what they're saying is we get that we're
doing this little piece of this in,
whether it's lab research or fertility
doctors or all sorts of things,
but it's really hard to put together the
whole story of the genetics revolution
and what it means for us
and for society. Yeah, man,
that is interesting about scientists,
right?
They're just concentrate on the task
at hand. Yeah. I mean it wasn't that,
that was like one of the big concerns
about the Manhattan project, right?
This is the task. The task is how
do you figure out how to do it.
So they figured out how to do it,
not the eventual in yes.
Consequence. So when Robert Oppenheimer,
who was the, the lead of the,
of the Manhattan project, when that
first bomb went off, I mean he has his,
his famous quote. It
exactly. You mean they,
the Co English common translation
was Holy Shit, what have we done?
And, and that's, and this science
is real, but it's not going to be,
it's not one person doing it.
I mean that's the whole like science
has been diffused at least with with
nuclear power.
It was a relatively small number of
people and it was a one or two states that
could do it.
Now with with precision gene editing,
I mean you get the Nobel prize for,
for figuring out how to do and you will
get the Nobel prize for figuring out how
to do CRISPR gene edits,
but to apply it once the
formula already exists,
you get like an a minus in
your high school biology class.
So this technology is out there.
It's cheap, it's accessible.
Did you go to the 2045 conference
in Manhattan a couple of years back?
Now, do you know about
all that? 2040 for that's,
that's part of the thing with
these transhumanists folks.
They believe that with their own
calculations of the exponential inclusive
technology that somewhere around
24 does a singularity. Yeah.
At the very least,
we're going to reach this point where
you're going to be able to either download
consciousness or have some sort of an
artificially intelligent sentient chains
hanging out with you. Yeah, so it's,
I'm involved, I'm on faculty for um,
one of the programs of singularity
university called exponential medicine.
And so we're thinking a lot about that.
Actually had an editor on the New York
Times a few weeks ago imagining a visit
to a fertility clinic in
the year 20, 45. And again,
because we were on this exponential
change is it's really hard for people to,
to internalize, to kind of feel
how fast these changes are coming.
I do think though, Ray Kurzweil, who's,
who's a really incredible genius,
he thinks that we are soon going to
get to a point now where our artificial
intelligence is self learning.
Because when you think about it, Ai,
if it gets to the point where it can
read something, read and comprehend,
like in seconds,
it will read every book ever
written in Cuban history.
And then it's when you have all these
doublings and all of this more knowledge,
you can imagine how that
would happen pretty quickly.
The counterargument against,
and I think that it will,
but I don't think that we're the, that
our human brains are, on one hand,
they're incredibly complex and they're
also kind of irrational. I mean,
we have all these different layers.
You have our lizard brain and
every decision that we make,
there's the rational decision.
But then there's all the
other stuff that our brains,
that doesn't even rise to the
level of our awareness that our,
that our brains are processing.
And right now we only really have one
really effective artificial intelligence
algorithm,
which is for pattern recognition.
But I think if you think of pattern
recognition as a core skill of what our
brains do, our brain's probably have
a thousand, 2000 different skills. Um,
but the core thing is whether we
reached this singularity moment or not,
these technologies are going to
become incredibly more powerful.
They're going to become increasingly
integrated into our lives and into our
beings. And part of our evolutionary
process. There's no longer, oh,
we just have our biological evolution
and our technological evolution,
and those are separate things.
They're connected.
It's going to be the weird
question of whether or not,
if an artificial intelligence is going
to be able to absorb all of the writing
that human beings have ever done and
really understand us. Yeah. Well,
they really still be able to understand
those just because they get all the
writing. So right now you would
say no. I would say no. Yeah.
But 20 years from now, 50 years
from now, a hundred years from now,
they could come up with a
reasonable facsimile. I mean, yeah,
they could figure out a way
to get it close enough. Yeah,
I know where it's like
her, like the, yeah. Yeah.
That's an essential point because I
think when people imagine this AI future,
they're imagining like some intimate
relationship with some artificial
intelligent, intelligent,
that feels just like a human.
I don't think that's going to
happen because it's its own one. No.
But just because Ai, it will be its own
form of intelligence. And it may not be,
frankly, you wouldn't want ais with these
brains like we have that have all these
different impulses that are
kind of imagining all this,
this crazy stuff. We're,
we may want them to be more rational than,
than we are.
So like chimpanzees or our close
relatives, they don't think just like us,
we're not, you know, we're not
expecting them to think like,
cause they're their own thing.
And I think AI's will be there on things.
Will we be interacting with them?
Will we be having sex with them? Yes.
But if they are there, it's not going
to be that. They're just like us.
We're going to, they're going to be
these things that live within us,
live with us, and together
we're going to evolve. Well,
they're certainly already better at
doing certain things like playing chess.
And it took a long time for an artificial
intelligence to be able to compete
against a real chess master.
But now they swamped them. Yeah.
So say learn quickly can incredibly
quickly they teach themselves. Yeah. So,
so first we had chess in
chess. People said, oh,
that's what it means to be a human.
The computers will never beat humans
at chess. Now it's like everyone says,
well no human could ever compete.
And then they said,
well there's this Chinese game of go,
which kind of when people hear look at it,
it looks kind of like checkers but
it's actually way more sophisticated.
Way More complicated than chess.
I heard that there are more moves in go,
more potential moves and there
are stars in the universe. Yes.
So so then they had Alphago that this,
this uh,
company deep mind,
which was later acquired by Google.
They built this algorithm that in 2016
defeated the world champions of going,
people thought that was,
we were decades away.
And then deep mind created this new
program called Alpha Zero Alpha zero with
Alpha go.
They gave it access to all of
the digitized games of go. So it,
it very quickly was able to learn from
how everybody else had played go alpha
zero.
They just said,
here are the basic rules of
go and they let alpha go.
Just play against itself with no other
experience other than here are the rules
and play against.
And in four days,
Alpha zero destroyed Alphago and then Alf
and Ned Alpha zero destroyed the world
champions of chess and destroyed every
other computer program that had ever
played chess.
And this again,
those computer programs had internalized
all of the chess games of grandmasters.
Alpha zero had not internalized any,
it just played against itself
for a few days. And then Shogi,
which is a Japanese traditional game,
kind of like chess,
it destroyed the grandmasters of that.
So that's what I'm saying is that these,
the world is changing.
It's changing so much faster than we
anticipate and we have to be as ready for
that as we can.
I think we need to come to grips with
the fact that we're way stupider than we
think.
Who are we,
what we think we're really intelligent
and we are in comparison to everything
else on this planet. Yeah. But in
comparison to what is possible,
we are really fucking dumb in comparison
to what this computer can do and what
the f the future of that computers.
And what maybe that computer's going to
redesign another computer. And I'm, again,
this is good, but I've got some, I got
some hiccups here. Yeah, no, it's true.
And yet the technology is us.
It's like this taste,
these not like this technology, some
alien force. We've, it's like this.
It's like we create art. We create.
We could, yeah. You use that.
You mentioned cities and are like,
we create these cities,
which are these incredible places where
dreams can happen to cities like here in
Los Angeles or New York
where, where, where I'm from.
So this technology is us and the challenge
is how can we make sure that this
technology serves our needs
rather than undermines our needs.
Yeah.
And whether or not our needs supersede
the needs of the human race or supersedes
the needs of the planet.
Yeah. It's, we're,
we're almost too much champ,
right.
To contemplate these critical
decisions in terms of like what,
how it's going to unfold from here
on out. Yeah. We really might not we,
but the people that are actually at
the tip of the spear of this stuff,
they really might be effecting the way
the planet is shaped and years from now.
And we're doing that now.
I mean we are,
there is an article
came out the other day.
There's a million species that
are on the verge of extinction.
We already driving all these other
species to extinction where warming the
planet.
So this is humans are that the determining
factor in many ways for how this
planet plays out. And that's why in my
mind everything comes back to vows. We,
you're right, we have this,
this lizard nature, this,
this monkey nature. It's,
it's who we are and that's,
I mean you wouldn't want to take that
away because that's the core of, of,
of what we are. And yet we are also a
species that has created philosophy.
We've created beautiful religions in
traditions and art. And the question is,
which version of us is going to lead
us into the future if it's this tribal
primate with these urges, like that's
really frightening. If we can say,
you know,
we've done better and worse in history
and we had this terrible second world war
and yet at the end of the Second
World War with American leadership,
the world came together.
We established at United Nations,
we established these
concepts of human rights.
Like you can't just kill everybody in
your own country and say, hey, it's,
it's just my business.
So we have this capability,
but it's always a struggle and we of
these forces are always at war with each
other in many ways. It's just
too much to think about. Yeah.
Well we have,
I know we do have to.
One of the things that has always been
amusing to me is that we seem to have
this insatiable desire to improve things,
and I've always wondered why I like it,
but is that maybe because this is
what human beings are here for?
It's what we do. It's who we are,
right? Yeah. But this is a product.
It's just a US being intelligent,
trying to survive against nature and
predators and weather and all the,
all the different issues that we came up
that we evolved growing up and dealing
with. And then now we just
want things to be better.
We just want things to be more convenient,
faster, but more data. Uh, you,
you're aware of Elon Musk's
neuro link check technology.
How much do you know about it? I know a
decent amount of, my friend Brian Johnson,
he has a company,
kernel.
There's a few different companies that
are trying to think about these brain
machine interfaces and
what are they trying to do?
Basically what they're trying to do is
to find a way to connect our brains to
our machines. And there's a little bit
of of progress from our brains are,
they're incredibly complicated and
they're messy. I mean, if there,
there's a lot that's that,
that, that's happening.
But we are increasingly figuring
out how to connect our brains to our
technology.
And so people are imagining a time
when we can do things like download,
download,
download ideas
or Upload Memories and upload it.
Isn't there some very early science
that is suggesting that this will be
possible, but it's, it's still the
very early days, the very early days.
But Ilan was giving the impression that
some time this year they're going to
release something. You know,
they may release something,
but it's not going to be something
that's going to change the world because
there's this,
that technology is way more nascent
than even the genetics technology that,
um, that I've been talking about.
So it's not like that there's that,
that at all remotely possible that this
year you're going to be able to like
upload a full memory or download
a full memory. But there,
there are little things that
are happening, but every,
every journey begins with a step.
But the technology is fairly transparent
as term in terms of like where the
state of the art is right now.
It is in that it's extremely early.
This stuff is real.
So when you think of like about systems
that we understand, I mentioned that we,
you know, we understand just a
little bit about genomics. Um,
we know less about the brain.
The brain is kind of the
great unknown of this unit.
We know more about the oceans than we
know about our brain. I mean he says,
we know very,
very little.
We understand that if you kind of stick
an electric current in somebody's brain,
like that's going to have you,
if you kind of shoot a spike
through somebody's head,
but really understanding how the brain
functions it, we're still in the very,
very early days.
So do you think the Kurzweils off with
this idea that you're going to be able to
download your consciousness
into a computer?
Cause that's one of the most controversial
ideas that he's come up with.
I think he's, I think he's off. Um,
based on your use of the word your,
so I mentioned that a month ago I
was in Kyoto and I was at this, um,
at this stem cell lab,
but I also went to another lab
of a guy named Hiroshi Ishiguro,
who's the world's leading
humanoid robot assist.
And so he's the guy who was on the cover
of wired and he's created these robot
avatars. And like I had a conversation
with this, this robot woman Erica,
and it was really interesting cause I
could see that like if I would smile she'd
smile and leaned forward. And
if I had like a, you know,
overexaggerated sad face,
she'd like change her expression
and she can have like, you know,
basic basic conversations.
But we're still a long way and so from,
from having full robotics,
but I had this for robotic
human interactions,
but I had this debate with Ishiguro and
he was saying that he thought that the
future of humanity was nonbiological,
that we were going to kind of unload
ourselves to these non biological entities
and that is how we would gain
our and mortality. And I, my arm,
I argued something very different.
I feel like we are biological beings.
I think we'll fully integrate
with our technology,
but if we ever become entirely
nonbiological, then that's not us.
Either.
We will have committed suicide
as a species or these robots,
or they will have killed us because even,
let's just say
that I could download my
entire consciousness to some
kind of robot unless it's
say that was possible.
That robot would be me for that first
exact moment when the transfer happened,
but then beyond that,
they wouldn't be me anymore because
there would be a whole other set of of
experience. But we're, but
certainly our interaction,
our connectivity with this
tech is going to be greater.
And so even if Kurzweil isn't exactly
right, he's directionally right. Give,
the problem would be that you would
be locked if they downloaded your
consciousness into some sort of a
bank of computers somewhere. Right?
Where are you if that's
your consciousness,
your consciousness is in
these ones and Zeros. Yeah.
I mean that's terrifying.
Terrifying.
As someone didn't like you and they said,
I'm going to make one version
of you suffer for all eternity.
Download you while you sleep. It's true,
but I have something worse than that.
Okay. Death. And so I think that
nobody is going to say, well,
I'm going to be Joe living a life or I'm
going to like not be Joe and I'll just
have my consciousness downloaded someplace
else. And so if the comparison is,
well, I've lived this life
and I don't want to die.
And so I'd rather kind of be
here in some kind of version.
And even if it's not me,
does something really,
I think some people will want that.
Not Everybody, some people will,
but they don't know what they're getting.
Right.
In terms of you don't know what that
experience is going to be like. Yeah.
Nor do you know if there is some sort of
a chemical gateway that happens in the
mind when you do expire and allows you
to pass through to the other dimension
that you're, your consciousness and your
soul longs to travel to. But no, you've,
I hope I, you're right about
that and my timing not right.
I've written about this in
my novel. It's like, yeah,
but I think kind of when you're dead,
you're just dead and the
good news for you as well,
just because I think that this kind of
immortality comes because time stops time
is this relative concept.
And so at the moment that you die,
that's immortality for you because
time stops flowing for you. Time is,
that's what Einstein taught us. Time
is this relative concept. Other people,
they're legitimately,
and there's no way to prove it,
feel that we have this soul and this soul
can travel to other, other dimensions.
I happen to believe that we are biological
beings and our experience of the soul,
whatever is connected to our biology,
when our biology stops functioning,
those experiences, whatever they are,
stop being accessible at least to us.
Have you had any psychedelic experiences?
I haven't and I was so tempted. We,
we started the interview talking
about my chocolate, shamanism,
anything I haven't in bed. I was
relaxed. I want to, I don't think so.
And I'll tell you why.
So I listened to the Michael Pale
and interviews and he had his great
conversation with Sam Harris.
And I really think that this
psilocybin stuff is Israel and just got
decriminalized. I know in Denver,
I was just there the other day. Um,
but as I said before,
I think that the ultimate
drug is us and so for me,
I would rather, and I definitely
think that our awareness that does,
he doesn't encompass everything that
is knowable. Everything that we,
that we could know, but we hem ourselves
in and if we want to get out of,
of those limitations,
certainly drugs are ways
that people have used for,
for many thousands of years.
But when you take the drug,
you're like taking the drug and
then you're not taking the drug.
Like I would rather, what does that mean?
It's like if you're taking psilocybin,
you're having this great experience,
but then tomorrow you're
not taking psilocybin and so
kind of your consciousness
has narrowed.
My aspiration would be to
recognize that the drug is us.
Did we want to expand our consciousness?
There are all kinds of ways,
whether it's meditation or awareness
or just you know, simple appreciation.
That's when I do these cacao ceremonies.
What I say is like,
you have this Cacau in front of you,
but it's not just this,
like think of the person in
Honduras who planted the seed,
the person who watered that seat,
the person who took the plant,
the person who paved the road
to bring the plan. And I just,
I just think that we can
expand our consciousness
through our own means and then
we always have access.
I hear what you're saying,
but you're saying this from a person
has never had certain experiences.
It's really preposterous.
You did experience what silicide can duty.
Yeah. You definitely wouldn't
be saying it this way.
You also wouldn't be thinking then you
take it and then you're not on it anymore
because it's profoundly
influential for the,
your perspective in regards to
the whole rest of your existence.
There's many people that have
had psychedelic experiences
to think about it as a
rebirth, that they've gone through
this and changed. Yeah. So,
but why would you have this rigid thought
process about drugs and not drugs,
but yet you don't have it about the
cow, which is a mild drug. Yeah.
And so I, you're right that it
may not be entirely consistent.
Some of the people you've described are
good friends of mine who've really done
it, and I've really, I've talked to them
about it and I'm hung endlessly curious.
So why don't you do it?
The reason is so far,
I have been on this journey to see what's
possible within myself and I'm still
on that journey.
I'm not,
I don't want to close off any possibility
for kind and assume that it would
close things off.
That's what's confusing.
It's just opening you up to a new
experience that other people found to be
profoundly influential.
Yeah. And Yeah. So,
so far you're very resistant to this. Like
you yeah. I'm talking to you like, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Like you can't wait to come
back and either their own rationale.
You're funny.
I will.
I will come back to this perspective of
a person who hasn't experienced anything.
You're so right.
And I think it's such a great point cause
I'm very close with actually that with
the Tibetans,
one of my closest friends is the
prime minister of the Tibet and exile
government. So I've been many times
to John Sala in, I've met with
his holiness the Dalai Lama many times
and the most incredible thing about
meeting with these guys and they,
they are all people who've found
these incredible states of heightened
consciousness so much that their brains
are changed when they go into the the
FMRI machines. But when you
have a conversation with them,
it's not like what we do like. Exactly.
And thank you for calling me out.
Like you say something,
I've already in my head countered what
you're saying before you're finished
saying,
and I'm like why you kept saying exactly
which part means that you made me a
little uncomfortable, which
is good. That's what we,
what we want. And these guys,
it's like you'd talk to them and they
would just be so tuned in to what you were
saying and they would just
kind of think about it.
Then you'd finish and then
they'd kind of look up. And then,
because we're Americans,
we want, you know,
somebody stops speaking like you have
to if you don't speak right away.
And then there was like a minute and
then it's like you're kind of looking
around, was it me? Did I say?
And then they would come back with
this incredibly thoughtful thing. So I,
you're right, you know, I don't
want to close off any possibility.
There are many different things
that we could, uh, could do.
The Path that I have been on and
certainly with this [inaudible] right.
Cacau is like a, a mild,
I mean, not a huge one,
but like a mild drug and
life is a mild jog. Um,
so the assignment is
not very mild. Yeah, no.
In my friends who have done it have said
exactly what he said, they say, I have a,
a good friend of mine who, uh, who
did it. Um, and then he said it just,
it showed me a path to a different
identity, a different consciousness.
And now he said, I don't do silicide
Bun, but I do daily meditation,
but I can see where I'd like to go,
what's possible. So I, I get that.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of different substances
out there that have very similar
profound effects.
Um,
there's a real thought,
and this is something that Terence
Mckenna described way back in the late
nineties,
early two thousands,
he believed that you're going to be able
to recreate a lot of psychedelic states
through virtual reality so that people
that don't want to actually do a drug
will be on, had to experience what it's
like to be on that drug. And that, I mean,
that's very theoretical
and hypothetical and yes,
you know, who knows whether or
not that's possible, but that,
that could be one other way that human
beings interface with technology.
So humans,
in my view,
are far more hackable than we think that,
that there are so many that we just
imagine our biology is being fixed.
But our biology is really variable.
Like I have a, a friend, um,
who's an anesthesiologist at Stanford
and she's done this experimentation of
just running, just like very mild
electric currents through people's brains.
And people have these very real
experiences and whether it's arousal or
something that it's,
that you're a, you're entering people's
minds through different ways. So you,
you talk about a,
about virtual reality when we are
entering a world where the pixelation of
virtual reality will be
equal to life and that,
so you're going to be in this VR
space and it's just, it will look,
it may smell,
it could eve with haptic suits.
It may feel just like life and our brains,
I don't know if you've done these things
with the, these, um, uh, these, uh,
VR glasses where you go
and you can see people,
you're just like in a,
in a hall and the put on the glasses and
now you're in an elevator going to the
top on the outside, like a window
cleaners elevator to the top of this, um,
highrise and there's a
little rickety board.
And then there's this cat at the end
of the board and they're saying, yeah,
you have to go, go save the cat.
And you've already seen that.
You're just in a hall. You know it
in your brain. Um, there's this cat.
Everybody's looking at you and you've
seen all these other people panic.
It's like, wow, when I'm
there, I'm going to be,
so I'm just going to go grab that cat.
And you're terrified.
Like you're trying to override your
lizard brain and your lizard brain saying
like, no, don't step up this. They'll
have that for our HTC vive. Yeah,
we need to set that up, Jim. We need a
two by four we put on the ground. Well,
it's incredible.
And so I think that this whole concept
of reality is at like that our technology
is going to be changing our sense
of reality. And then what's real,
like if you feel arousal in your brain
because of an electric current or you
feel it because you're with
your girlfriend or wife
or reading a magazine or
whatever, is that different?
Is One real and one not real?
And I think that that's,
there's real big issues here.
General mean that is the Matrix,
right? Yeah. I mean the idea that,
and if it feels better and it's
more enjoyable than real life,
what is going to stop people from doing
the Ray Kurzweil deal and downloading
yourself into this, this
dimension? Well, and not much.
Whether it's possible to do
a full download or not me,
I think that's an open question,
but whether people are going to be more
comfortable living in these alternative
worlds and whether we're booked,
we're going to be able to say, oh no,
that is the fake world. Like if you're
in this virtual world, but your,
do you have friends in that world,
you're interacting in that world.
You have experiences that feel every bit
as real in that world as in our world
and people say, oh no, that's not
real. Those, those aren't your friends.
Like even now, like you know we
all people with global lives,
you kind of have these friends.
Like I have a good friend in Mongolia.
We talk all the time.
Do you ever see them in person?
Once it all hell like once every
year or two. It's great to see him.
That's a real person though.
You know it's a,
it's a real that someone
who actually not like a pen.
It was a control plane that you
actually do know him. Gonna have to say.
But if it was someone that you only talk
to online and they lived in Mongolia,
that's where things get weird.
It's true.
But let's just say hyper falling that
hypothetical. You have that person,
they're part of your whole life
and you're there with you there.
Are they with you through
your life experiences?
You call them up when you're sad.
Like is it so essential that
you've met that person physically?
Like is that the core of what it means
to be someone's friend that you was not
essential but it means a lot.
It does. And I, and so I,
I mean because we are not like we are
these physical beings and we are these
virtual beings. But figuring out what's
the balance is going to be really tricky.
Yeah.
What is the balance?
What I'm worried about augmented
reality too. Cause I, you know,
when you see people that you snapchat
filters and give themselves doggy years
and stuff like that,
like yeah.
Well how long before that is just
something that people choose to turn on or
turn off about life itself.
Yeah.
Like you'll be able to see the world
through different lenses. The Sky,
it could be a different color. The
plants could be a different color. Yeah.
I write about this in one of
my novels, Eternal Sonata, um,
where I think we're just going to
have these contact lenses and I'm,
and it'll be different kinds
of information based on
what people want. I mean,
like I'll meet with you and it'll
say, all right, this is Joe,
here's a little bit of background,
whatever,
and we'll have useful information.
Or you're walking around
a city and you'll be,
get little alerts of things
you might do or, or history.
And so I think that that's what they
were thinking about with Google glasses.
Right? Yeah. I know.
But he just was so annoying that he wanted
to kill these two weird, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. It was just too, everybody
felt like they were getting filmed.
They were, when you were walking
around with Google glasses on,
you assume that people were recording
everything. It was very strange.
But I think that's another
thing that we're just,
all of our lives are going to be
recorded. Of course. Yeah. Now,
do you think that that's going to come
in the form of a contact lens or do you
think it's going to come in the form of
like ski goggles that you're going to
put on and snowing where nobody
wants to look like an idiot.
And so in the beginning, no, but
in the beginning, all of these,
you talked about Michael Douglas with
this or like that. My favorite one is, um,
is Kurt Russell in escape from New York?
What do you have there?
It's like this really cool tech.
Like he,
he finally gets out of this Manhattan
Hell and he's got this phone and it's like
this big and it's so crazy cell
phone. This freeze, it's like very,
very early days.
And so you know,
now we have these kind of glasses and
there's like a little bit of a little bit
of Cachet, but all I'm has a cell phone
that's that big. It'd be seen that. No,
I was at the Verizon store. Yeah, I
think it's like an attachment. Earnest.
An accessory to a phone. Yeah. You can
bring it with you as intervention. Fine.
Not Bring your other phone.
That's the idea behind it. Yeah.
So like you could decide,
well I'm going out,
let me just bring my tiny phone
for essentials. All this tiny,
I mean the funds are going
to get quote unquote,
phones are just going to get so smart.
So I say they're going
to come inside of it.
So you'll have like a little contact lens,
maybe a little thing in your ear.
Maybe like a little permanent implant
in your behind your tooth or one of your
teeth. They'll replace a
tooth with a computer. Well,
you pipe it into your nerves.
Any kinds of crazy stuff you can think
of that it's probably going to happen.
And some of it, some of it will take,
some of it won't. Right, right. Yeah,
it seems like that's what
we're going to have to see.
Like how it plays out and that's one of
the things when you were talking about
scientists that are
working on these things,
they're working on what's
right in front of them.
They're not looking at the
greater landscape itself
in terms of what the future
holds.
It's not their job.
And that's why we need other people and
I certainly see myself or those people.
You and who else, who would you elect
if Trump came to you and said, Jamie,
we've got problems when we need to
figure out the future, what should we do?
So was certainly the move. We need to
have a mix of different kinds of people.
And so I, I'm certainly people like me
who are kind of big picture futurists.
We need that. We need scientists. I
work with some really incredible sign.
I did an event at Harvard last week
with George Church who kind of like the
Living Charles Darwin,
David Sinclair,
who you know has been on this program
is a friend of mine working on life
extension and we need people
just from all backgrounds.
And so like I would say like we
need people, we need poor people,
we need people from developing world.
We need to all kinds of people.
But in terms of the people who are kind
of articulating the big picture of the
world and what are the
challenges that we're facing,
I certainly put myself in that category.
People like you've all Noah Harari,
he was just kind of big
also kind of big thinkers.
People like Sid Mukherjee Am.
I just think we have to articulate the
big picture and we have to do it in a way
so that people can see themselves
in this story and then,
and then enter into the conversation.
Are you writing this book?
Just to sort of educate people and let
them understand exactly what is going on
and that it is a really volatile
and chaotic and amazing time.
And that all these things are, or are
you, or are you doing this book too?
But what are, what, what
essentially was hacking Dharma look,
what was the motivation behind it? Was it
for a person like me or was it for the,
the everyone like is for, for everyone.
And so what I really wanted you to,
so the background's give be gift. I can
give you just a little bit of background.
So more than 20 years ago I was working
on the National Security Council and my
then boss, um, Richard Clark,
who was then this obscure White House
official who is jumping up and down saying
we need to be focusing on terrorism
and al Qaeda and bin Laden.
And he was trying to tell everybody
and nobody was paying attention to is
totally marginalized.
And when nine 11 happened and Dick's
memo was on George Bush's desk saying
exactly that we need to focus on al Qaeda,
here's what's going to happen to,
and Dick even before then would always
tell me that if everyone in Washington
was focusing on one thing,
you can be sure there was something much
more important that was being missed.
And so more than 20 years ago,
I was looking around,
I saw all these little pieces of
disparate information and I came to the
conclusion that the genetics revolution
was going to change everything.
So I educated myself,
I started writing articles.
I was invited to testify before Congress
and then to try to get that story out,
I was, I started, I wrote my, my two
most recent near term Scifi novels,
Genesis Code and Eternal Sonata.
And when I was on book tours for those,
and I explained the science,
uh,
to people the way I kind of a self
educated citizen scientist, um,
and a novelist would explain the science,
all of a sudden people got it.
And that was when I realized I needed
to write a book about the genetics
revolution that people could
absorb that wouldn't scare people.
But my mission for the book is that
this stuff, as we've talked about,
it's so important that everybody
needs to be part of the conversation.
We have this brief window and what I'm
calling for is this species wide dialogue
on the future of human genetic
and genetic engineering.
And I have a whole game plan, uh, in
the book about what people can do,
how they can get involved a people
individually on a national level.
We have to put a lot of pressure
on our elected leaders and say,
stop focusing on the crap.
There is really important stuff that
needs to be addressed and we need
leadership. I'm going to, I'm speaking
on, uh, in, uh, in Congress, um,
or week and a half from now
talking about about these dishes.
So we need to have an,
on an international level,
we have to have some kind
of international system.
We're so far away from
being able to do that.
We don't even know what the standards are,
but we have to be pushing.
And so I know you think of it in terms
of like the same way we have with look
nuclear weapons. Yeah. In
a way. In many ways. Yeah.
But the thing is with nuclear weapons,
a lot of that happened at the state level,
at the country level. This needs to
happen at a popular level and at a, uh,
at a government level.
So the only way that those that's going
to happen effectively is we need a real
comprehensive education on the subject.
It's not something that
people can just guess. Right.
You need to know what's the consequences,
what, where we're at right now. Yeah.
Right. Yeah. And that's,
and that's like Sanjay
Gupta had a wonderful quote
that's actually on the cover
of my book, which is if you can read
one book on the future of our species,
this is it.
So what I've tried to do is to say like,
if you just want to go to one place
to understand what's happening,
what's at stake, what it means
for you, and what you can do now.
If you want to get an involved,
I've tried to do that.
But then ironically I'm now like,
as I mentioned,
being asked to speak to thousands of
doctors and scientists because they're all
reading this book and they're saying this
is, this is positioning my work in a,
in a much bigger context.
Sanjaya goop does a very interesting
cat cause he was very anti marijuana and
then started doing research on it and
then totally flipped 180 degrees. Yeah.
Which to me is a great
sign of both humility and
intelligence I recognize of the
data was different than
his presuppositions. Yeah.
He had these prejudices that
were very common. Yeah. Yeah.
Now when you speak to Congress,
what do you,
do they brief you in terms of like what
they would like specifically for you to
address? No. So this one, um, it's um,
I've been asked to go and speak in a lot
of members of congress who are going to
be invited. And what I'm
going to tell them is, look,
this is really important.
Our congress is not doing enough and
here are the things that we need to do.
And what are you going to say to try
to really get it into their head?
What I'm gonna say is that the
genetics revolution is here.
If we don't have a system,
if you don't have a rational system to
manage it, if we don't have a system.
You talked about public education.
The challenge that we faced in the United
States is we traditionally have had a
representative democracy and now we're
transitioning from a representative
democracy to a popular democracy.
So Switzerland has a popular democracy,
but they have like really well
educated people who are able,
who have enough information
to make smart decisions.
We have an educated our public and yet
the public is making big decisions and a
lot of it is happening
just on a gut feeling.
That's what's happening with trade
agreements where people just have,
I have a feeling it's bad without,
you know, the ability to, to,
to really get into the, into the details.
And so we are having that transition,
which means there's a lot
of responsibility on us to
educate our public and it's
just, it's a tragedy. We
treat people in this country.
Like you can just throw
people away like you somebody.
If you're in some crappy school
system and you know your, your,
your chances of success are so minimized,
not because of anything that you've done
just because of your circumstances and
it's unacceptable. It is only, I mean,
the equal opportunity is what we
really should all strive for us.
And I think some people conflate that
with a op equal success and you're not
going to get the same equality of outcome.
You're going to get different,
different amounts of ever and different
people are qualified or more talented at
different things.
But what I'm worried about is what I
said initially that some people are going
to get ahold of this stuff quickly and
it's going to give them an a massive
advantage. Yes. Sort
of like, I mean if you,
the first person that has the
ability to go forward in time,
five minutes is going to be able to
manipulate the stock market unprecedented
way. Yeah. I don't think that that's
really possible in our lifetime,
but that's the kind of
thing I'm talking about.
You could get so far ahead that if
we're talking about competition,
there will be no catching up.
They'd big,
you don't have to travel in time to do
that. Right. But I'm saying if that was,
if it was algae,
but there's real technologies that are
likely to happen which are going to
confer billions,
tens,
hundreds of billions of dollars of benefit
of advantage. Yeah. And that stuff is,
is happening now.
And this is the concern with getting
behind countries like China cause if they
get ahead of us or something like that,
when they were already moving in this
direction in terms of technology. Yeah.
So I am a proud American. My father
and grandparents came here as refugees.
I believe in what this country
at our best stands for.
I want us to continue to be the country
that setting an example for the rest of
the world that is articulating what our
ideals of responsibility and governance,
good governance and accountability and
all these things that we've championed.
And because of that,
I want us to get our act
together politically and I
want us to be the leading
technological country in the world.
Um, and so I think that's what's,
what's its taken.
We're losing so much time because there
was a time in the period after the
Second World War where we recognize
that technological leadership was the
foundation for everything else we were,
we had recreated the world out
of the ashes of the, of the war.
But we realized that we needed
to have the economic growth.
We needed to have the competition, we
needed to have these technologies and we,
it was a miracle.
What we've,
what we've done and now we've lost
our focus and we have to regain it.
The way I look at humans and the way I
look at the human race today in 2019 it's
like we're driving very fast through fog
and it's very difficult to see what's
in front of us.
Yep.
When I look back at how long have you
ever written any hg wells but some of his
predictions about the future?
Really interesting cause he, he,
he was pretty close on quite a few things,
but that that vision is to be able to
sit there and use your imagination,
close your eyes and think what is
this going to be like, what is, what,
what we're dealing with now and opposed
to as opposed to what, 2119 right.
What does, which is similar to
the HG wells versus us. Right.
What the fuck is that going to be like?
Like yeah.
Is there going to be a time where
there are no diseases there,
there is no death and that we just have
to regulate population control in some
sort of a other manner and
the only way people die,
they're going to die from accidents
and things along those lines. But,
but mortality in terms of old age,
I mean this is,
that's a according to Davidson
Claire, this is a fixable issue. Yeah.
You know how to have,
when they fix it,
they fix it in 20 years
or 30 years or 50 years.
David is a friend and I and I
have a whole chapter and shit.
I don't want to misquote.
Nice.
I have a whole chapter in the book on
the science of of human life extension.
So I think definitely it's real that
we going to live healthier longer.
We're going to harness
our technology if that.
I don't think that in mortality it that
biological and mortality is in is in the
cards.
Maybe not in mortality because we'll still
be biologically vulnerable with their
hearts and brains on
stuff, but aging, yeah,
I think we will age slower and we will
live healthier longer and I think it's,
it's going to be great.
The back to your ear core point.
I mean that's the reason why I also write
science fiction is that the world of
science is changing so fast that we really
need to apply a lot of imagination to
imagine where it's going.
Because if you're just looking
at what's happening now,
it's like this train is going to speed by,
we have to kind of imagine,
it's like Wayne Gretzky. We have to
imagine where the puck is going to be,
not where it is now. I mentioned George
Church who's like, he's at Harvard,
he's like the the Living Charles Darwin.
And I do a lot of speaking alongside
George and it's become our little thing
that he says that he reads,
um, science fiction like mine.
And then imagine says, well, that's
pretty cool. How can we do that?
And what I do is I look at the research
coming out of labs like Georges and I
sat, right? Well that's where we are now.
What's that going to
mean in 2050 100 years?
And so we have to that the science fiction
plays a more important role than it
ever has and kind of
imagining where we're going.
And it's that imagining that
allows us to try to say, well,
what if that's one of the
options of where we're going?
What are the decisions that we need to
make now so that we can have a better
outcome rather than a worst one?
If you're gambling person,
I don't know if you are.
Yeah,
but if I had to give you 100 bucks
to put on something in 20 years,
it's going to be profoundly just,
it changed.
It's going to change us in a way that
is something that we're not really
prepared to understand or deal with.
What do you think that's going to be?
I think it's going to be predictive
genetics. They were going to have,
all right now it's like you go
to your doctor when you're sick.
You could have been,
this could have been some genetic disorder
that you had from the moment you were
conceived and it was ticking and it was
ticking and you showed up 50 years later
when that's been manifest.
So it's going to be very different.
You're taking your kid home
from the hospital, your
newborn, and the doctor says,
Hey, congratulations.
This is really great,
but just Fyi now your kid has
a 50% greater than average
chance of getting early
onset Alzheimer's 50 years
from now and your cat.
Your kid has a really great chance
of being phenomenal at abstract math.
Like,
how are we going to think about,
how are we to think about what it means
to be human when we have all of that
information? And there are things
now that we call fate and it's, it's,
it's just a different model. And so
I think that, and once we have that,
that's gonna change a
lot of a lot of things.
It's going to fundamentally
transform our health care.
What we call healthcare
now is really sick care.
You show up with a symptom and this is
going to be predictive and it's going to
change the we,
the way we make babies because people are
going to have real choices about which
embryos to implant.
And we're going to have a
lot of information about a
re a lot of really intimate
stuff. So you feel like genetic
manipulation and genetic engineering,
genetic understanding, genetic knowledge,
and then applied genetic medicine. Yeah.
So those are going to be the big
changes in the next 20 years,
even more so than technology,
which it's interconnected because these,
there's really, it's like a super
convergence of these technologies.
So the the genetics revolution is the
artificial intelligence revolution in a
sense that the complexity
of genetics is so great,
it's way beyond what our brains
on their own could process.
And so really they're,
all these technologies are touching each
other and so the biological models are
now influencing the AI.
So for example,
we are coming to the
limits of silicon storage,
but DNA has unlimited storage capacity.
So it's the,
the, the, as I've said before,
the kind of the between biology and AI
or genetics and AI is going to be very
blurry. Yeah. That is a, an
interesting concept, right?
The idea of storing information in DNA
and that that has been discussed. Yeah.
Which the DNA is the greatest information
storage mechanism ever imagined that
the question is what happens when you do
store things in there and how does that
information interact with all the rest
of the stuff that's in your body already?
Well, I mean if you can do
it in your body, you could,
doesn't have to be angels nearby body.
Just think of like your,
your DNA has 4 billion years of history
and it's done a great job of recording
it. It's incredible. I can, my, my old
eight track tapes, they haven't lasted.
That is a squirrely concept that you have
all that data inside your head. I mean,
that's also when people make,
when they try to understand
instincts yeah. That people have,
that these are some sort of
genetically encoded memories, right?
Some understanding of things that
are dangerous and that these, the,
they're in there because this is how
we've learned over the years without
actually having experienced these things
personally. Yeah. Yeah. No. So that's,
it's baked in. Our genetics are
baked into us. And so, you know,
I don't know if you've been to Indonesia,
but while I was in Indonesia and I went
to this place called Komodo island.
Oh Wow. Well, the, like a motor guides.
And it was fascinating because it's
like you can tell they don't have
plaintiff's attorney, so here's walking
around. They're all these Komodo dragons.
And so yeah, these are like the
most deadly creatures on earth.
And there's like some little guy
with a little stick and it's like,
well how effective is that stick?
But the way it works,
so you're just walking
around just walking around.
Cause they come over checks when they're
not killing people or killing animals,
they're just sitting there.
And so it's pretty scary.
Do they ever get jack to people ever go
there and get bitten and they, they say,
oh it's that only a few times a year.
It's like wow, a few times. Yeah,
that seems like a lot. I
was a year. There's a lot.
But the way it works for a Komodo Dragon,
mother lays the egg and then buries the
egg and then forgets where the egg is.
And then let's just say that this egg
hatches and this little Komodo dragon
comes out and the mother sees
her own baby Komodo Dragon.
She'll eat it in a second. Oh Jesus.
And so if you're a Komodo Dragon,
you better have your entire survival
strategy baked into your DNA because
nobody's teaching you anything.
And so for us,
we have this sense that it's like
parenting is really important.
It is environment is really important.
It is.
But so much of who and what we are is
baked in to our genetics and I think
that's, that's going to be this challenge
that we're going to see ourselves as
increasingly genetic beings.
We can't become genetic determinist
think that we're just genetics,
but we're going to know a lot more.
We're going to demystify a lot of
what it means to be human poop. Yeah,
teeth is right, but are we going
to lose the romance and the,
the just the randomness
of life because of that.
That's what people are
concerned with, right? Like if,
if we have some sort
of genetic uniformity,
I mean especially in particularly
with like things like intelligence
and athletic performance,
we're not going to appreciate freaks
as much or maybe we'll all want to be
freaks. Freaks are the ones who push us
into not going to want to be a moron.
Well, your your question, it's,
it's the essential question.
It's like what makes a human
a human isn't December.
We have higher Iq that doesn't make you
a better human that makes you someone
with a higher Iq.
But how are we going to think about
constructing societies when it's up to us?
Like if we are going to say
we value certain people,
certain ideas,
I think we're going to need artists.
Like right now people like artists are
sometimes in the mainstream and sometime
they're on the fringe,
but artists are going to be maybe the
most important people in this new world.
And right,
like right now in hospitals and we have
kind of a hierarchy and like the most
technical people are the people who are
valued the most and the least technical
people,
like some of the nurses or nurse's aides
are the people who are often valued and
paid the least.
But when technology can do
these technological feats,
what's going to be left is how can
we be great humans? How can we emote?
How can we connect?
How can we create art?
And if we get swept away by
this tide of science, as in,
you know, how excited I am about the size
a bit and we could really undermine our
humanity, right? And as for humans,
what humans value is many aspects
of that humanity are the creations,
the literature things. We, we, we,
when you read someone's great pros,
you're,
you're reading like an
insight into their mind.
And that's what's interesting
about it, right? He's like, yes,
you're not going to get that
from just ones and Zeros.
Yeah. And that's, and there,
there will always be this
way we call it mystery.
And even if we can do a genetic
analysis of Shakespeare and Mozart and,
and whatever, like it's still miraculous
and we need to celebrate that.
And we can't,
we can't allow us to say that we are just
our genetics or even just our biology.
But we also can't just say
biology has nothing to do with it.
And especially because we're going to
know more about our biology and about our,
our, our differences. And
that's, that's normal.
I mean it used to be in the
old days that everyone thought,
well God is weather and now we
understand weather. Pretty much a,
nobody is saying, oh that lightening,
that's God is delivering a message.
It could be,
but we still like we still have that
mystery and I think that it's in some ways
it's about our orientation,
like how do we make sure that
we keep this view of life,
that we have artists and humanists who
are just at the core of this conversation
about where we're going.
What if that mystery ultimately turns
out to just be ignorance and that as you
develop more and more understand
and there's less and less mystery,
would we like to be less smart?
What we like to be the more
overwhelmed by possibility?
It could be. I think those would
be part of what romance is.
It could be and certainly like the unknown
every we wake up every morning and we
just don't know the answer.
And there's some people like to going
back to the issues of of life extension.
There are some people who say,
well that death is essential
for appreciating life. I,
I talk about this stuff all around.
And then there are people who say you and
you're talking about eliminating these
terrible diseases,
but I know somebody who had that terrible
disease and their suffering was a gift
to everybody else because we all had
more humanity in response to their
suffering. I look, well
that's kind of screwed up.
I'd prefer them to not
have that suffering,
but to those people were thinking
wacky, it's Wacky, but we need to like,
I totally agree with you that if we allow
ourselves to get swept away with this
kind of scientific determinism,
if we don't say we really value our
humanistic traditions are artists,
our cultures, we could get lost
and with have become obsolete,
we could become obsolete,
but we could also just become less human.
And there's something
wonderful and there's magic.
And do think that monkeys used to
think, man, can't become a human.
We become less monkey.
You don't know what I'm saying.
But no being looks in the mirror and
recognizes that they are evolving here.
We've what we've only been, homo sapiens
are about 300,000 years. Right? Um,
so we just, it's hard. We know
where we've come from cause you,
you see all those little charts
from high school biology,
but it's really hard for people to imagine
being something else in the future.
It's, it's, it's outside of
our, of our consciousness.
And So said she will square.
Yeah. And we are monkeys.
It just that we've redefined
our monkey thing. You know,
we do it with you in a
little different way.
That's what I was kind of getting out.
Are you concerned at all
with artificial life?
Are you concerned about the propagation
of, of artificial intelligence? Well,
there are different kinds
of artificial life. So, um,
one is artificial intelligence and I
know people like Elon Musk and Stephen
Hawking are, are afraid. Terrified.
Yeah. And I think that, that we need,
whether it's right or not,
I think it's great for us to focus on
those risks because if we just say, oh,
that's,
that's crazy and we don't focus on it,
it increases the likelihood
of these bad things happening.
So Kudos to Elon Musk,
but I also think that we are,
we're have a long way away from that
threat and we are and we will be enormous
beneficiaries of these technologies.
And that's why my,
I don't want to sound
like a broken record,
but that's why I keep saying
it's all about values.
If I think we should take those threats
very seriously and then say his are so
abstract and we don't agree on them,
it's true, but like, like Elon Musk,
I mean they've set up this,
this institute where to say well what
are the dangers and then what are the
things that we can do now?
What are standards that we
can integrate for example,
into our computer programming.
And so I mentioned my World
Health Organization a committee.
The question is well what are the,
what are the standards
that we can integrate into
scientific culture that's not
going to cure everything
but it may increase the
likelihood we'll have a better
rather than worse outcome.
But isn't there an inherent danger in
other companies or other countries rather
not complying with any
standards that we serve?
Because it would be anti competitive.
Yes. Like that would, that would,
it would somehow or another diminished
comp competition or diminish their
competitive edge. It's true. And that's
why, and that's the balance that we're,
we're going to need to need to
hold. It's, and it's really hard,
but we have a window of opportunity
now to try to get ahead of that.
And like I said, we have chemical
weapons, biological weapons,
nuclear weapons where we've
had international standards
that have roughly held,
I mean there was a time when slavery
was the norm and there was a movement to
say this is, this is wrong.
And it was largely successful.
So we have history of being
more successful rather than,
uh, than less. And I think that's
the goal. But you're right. I mean,
this is a race between the
technology and the best values.
Mine real concerned about
artificial intelligence is
that this paradigm shifting
moment will happen before we recognize
it's happening and then it'll be too late.
Yes, that's exactly right. And
that's like I saying, that's,
that's why I've written the book.
That's why I'm out on the road so
much talking to people. Why, why?
It's such an honor for me
to be in pleasure for me
to be here with you talking
about it cause we have to reach out and
I to people when people can't be afraid
of entering this conversation because it
feels too technical or feels like it's
somebody else's business.
This is all of our business because this
is all of our lives and it's all of our
futures.
So if in the future you think 20 years,
the thing that's going to really change
the most is predictive genetics and able
be able to predict
accurately a person's health.
What do you help in life,
health and love?
What do you think is going
to be the biggest detriment
for all the stuff and the
thing that we have to avoid the most?
Yeah, so one is, as I mentioned,
this determinism just because if we just
10 of take our sense of wonder about
what it means to be a human away,
like that's really going to harm us.
We talked about equity and access to
these technologies and the technologies
don't even need to be real in
order to have a negative impact.
So in India,
there are no significant
genetic differences between
people in different castes,
but the caste system has been maintained
for thousands of years because people
just have accepted these, uh,
these differences. So this,
it's a whole new way of,
of understanding what is a human and it's
really going to be complicated and we
aren't ready for it. We weren't
ready for it. Culturally,
we aren't ready for it educationally.
Certainly our political leaders aren't
paying much of any attention to all of us
who have a huge job. Oof. Oof.
So when you sit down and you
give this speech to Congress,
yeah.
What,
what are you anticipating from them in
terms of like what do you think that
there's anything that they can do
now to absolutely certain steps. Yes.
So a few things.
One is we need to have a national
education campaign. I mean,
this is so important.
I would say it's on the future of genetics
revolution and of AI because I think
it's just,
it's crazy
that we aren't focusing on these.
Like I, I learned French in,
in um, in grade school and high
school and I'm happy to speak French,
but I would rather have people say this
is really important stuff. So that's, uh,
that's number one.
Number two is we need to make sure that
we have a functioning regulatory system
in this country and every country,
and I do a lot of of comparative work
and like the United Kingdom and they're
really well organized.
They have a national healthcare system
which allows them at a national level to
kind of think about longterm care
and the tradeoffs in this country.
Average person changes
health plans every 18 months.
And I was talking with somebody
the other night and they were,
they were working on a predictive health
company and they said their first idea
was they were going to sell
this information to a health
insurers because like,
wouldn't this be great if you could?
Hell if you're a health
insurer and you could,
you had somebody who was your
client and you could say, hey,
here's some information.
You can live healthier and you're not
going to have this disease 20 years from
now. And when he found out
is the health insurers,
they could have cared less
because people were just,
they were only going to be part
of it for a year and a half.
So we really need to think differently
about how do we invest in people over the
course of their lives.
And certainly education is one,
but thinking longterm about
health and wellbeing is another.
What do you think is going to be the
first technological innovation in terms of
like what,
what's already on the pipeline right now
that's going to radically alter human
beings so radically?
I think it's going to be
the end of procreative sex.
And so when we stop conceiving our babies
through sex and we're selecting our
embryos,
that's going to open up this
massive realm of possibility.
And certainly when we expand the number
of fertilized eggs that were choosing
from that,
that is really,
I think that's the kind of the killer
application of genetics to the future of
human life.
Do you see that being attainable to the
general population anytime in the near
future? Like once it starts, once
the technology gets established,
it seems like it's going to be wealthier
people that are going to have access to
it first, right? Well it
depends, probably yes.
But when you think about right now we
have all these people who are born with
these terrible, in many cases, deadly
genetic diseases and disorders.
And what is this societal expenditure
for lifetime care for all those people?
I mean this is huge,
huge amounts of money.
So if we were to eliminate many
of not the people, but eliminate,
prevent those disease diseases and
disorders from taking place in the first
place, and we could use that
money to provide, to provide, um,
IVF and embryo screening to everybody
using just the economic models now.
But then there's another issue
that we have to talk about this.
It's really sensitive. So I talk a
lot about this. Um, but there are,
and I talk in the book about people
with Down Syndrome and I have a lot of
friends who have kids
with downs downstairs,
but these Keller wonderful kids and they
deserve every opportunity to thrive the
same as as everybody else. And I'm really
sensitive because people say, well, Hey,
if you're, and I say like down
syndrome is largely not going there.
I'm going to be newborns with Down
Syndrome 10 or 20 years from now.
So we will say,
well what are you saying about my kids?
Like are you saying that if this is
going to be eliminated that my kid has a
less of a right to be as somebody else.
And I always say absolutely not.
And we need to be extremely sensitive
that we're not dehumanizing people.
But if you have fifth,
10 or 15 fertilized eggs in a lab and
you have to pick which one gets implanted
in the mother and one of them will just
has a disease like taste acts or sickle
cell disease where they're going
to die before they're 10 years old,
would you choose affirmatively choose to
implant that embryo versus the nine or
14 or whatever the number
is of of other ones.
And so these are really sensitive things
and we can't be blahzay about them.
Um,
but we will have these choices and we're
going to have to figure out how do we
make them,
well,
I think there's also a real possibility
of them being able to fix that. Yeah.
And some things will be fixable and
some things won't. And so that's,
that's why though for these, for these
single gene mutation, uh, disorders,
now there's a debate. I was speaking
in Berkeley, uh, the other day.
And so I was talking about
these two options. One is
embryo selection and one is,
is gene editing. And so there were
different people who got up, says, oh no,
we can do embryo selection.
That's the way and that we should,
we should prevent these diseases.
But gene editing that's going too
far. That's, that's playing God.
And so for different things, there'll
be different options. Do you, when you,
when you hear that,
that that's going too far.
W who's usually saying that there's
two groups in one is certainly in the
religious community were saying,
well this is his plan gun. Um,
but there's another kind of,
it's like a progressive community who's,
who are the kinds of people who were
uncomfortable with genetically modified
crops and people who are
saying that once that the,
that there's this slippery slope that
once we start making what are called
germline genetic modification.
So germline is that our,
our sperm eggs and embryos,
if you make a change to an adult human,
it doesn't pass to their kids.
If you make a change to a sperm and
egg or an embryo, it will pass on.
And so there are a lot of
people who are saying, well,
we don't understand the genetics well
enough to make these changes that will
last forever. I'm not
in that, in that view.
I just think that we need to be cautious.
I may need to weigh the Ben the risks and
the benefits of everything that we do.
Do you think we do know enough
about those changes in order?
It depends because if we're, it depends
on what we're selecting against.
Like if the thing we're selecting
against is some kind of terrible genetic
disease that's going to somebody
when they're a little kid,
we have a lot of latitude because
the alternative is death. Right?
And that's why I was so critical of this
Chinese, um, biophysicist who created,
who genetically engineered these two
little girls born in China last year
because he wasn't in the gene edits,
they weren't probably weren't successful.
It wasn't to eliminate
some disease or disorder.
He was trying to confer the benefit of a,
of increased resistance to HIV.
And so I think that we need to be very
mindful and we need to be doing kind of a
cost benefit analysis of the different
things at different interventions.
And there was an unintended side
effect of this war, the believer,
perceived potential, unintended side
effect. And that's increased intelligence.
It's a, it's a possibility. So how
did this gene, so this gene is,
it's called a CCR five is this gene.
And when it was disrupted
in some mouse studies,
those mice became a little
bit able to navigate mazes.
And so that was what led people to believe
that this disruption of the CCR five
could potentially lead to that kind of
change in human. Nobody really knows.
There's lots of things that happen in mice
that don't have analogs in, in humans.
And that was why it was so irresponsible
is that this, this scientist in secret,
um, made these, uh, these gene gene edits,
he didn't get a proper consent
from the parents. Um, yeah,
yes. And enhanced China
because it's China. Rod. Yeah.
I mean, he can, they were,
the parents were all manipulated and
it's real. Yeah. And so that's the thing.
So you're exactly right. Like we're
humans, we're nuts as a species and so,
and so we need to try to establish some
kind of guide rails guard rails about
what's okay, what we're comfortable
with, what we're, what we're not.
Now this guy is not operating
in an isolated incidence.
There's gotta be a shit ton of that
going on right now as we're talking,
it's China. What do you think is
happening over there? And I think it,
China has a lot of money.
They have brilliant people and they
have a government that is hell bent on
leading the world in advanced
technology and thick.
The scientific culture in China is
just a very different than it is here.
And so we know what we know, but we don't
know what we don't know. And that's,
it's a really,
really big deal because China is in
many ways a wild west and the technology
exists to do some really big stuff.
And that's,
that's why we have to at least
try to establish standards.
Will we succeed? Fully know, but maybe
we can do better than, than worse.
Are you anticipating seeing like a lot
of freaky things come out of China? Yes.
Whoa. You said that very quick. Yeah,
no, it's true. I suppose I spend,
I spend a lot of time in China I,
and this, it's a different name,
but the thing with China,
China had this great ancient civilization,
but they destroyed their own civilization
in the great leap forward and the
Cultural Revolution. They,
they burned their books.
They smashed their own and
historic relics and so it's really,
it's a society many ways that starting
from scratch and so all of these norms
that people get inherit
through their traditions.
China in many ways doesn't
have and so and so it's,
it's a very different,
and China is growing.
I mean they are increasingly powerful
and China is going to be a major voice if
forced,
defining the world of the 21st century.
That's why America has
to get its act together.
That's a hard concept for us to grasp.
When we think about the fact
that they had the Great Wall,
they have so much ancient
art and architecture.
We just assume they're a really old
culture. They are, but they wiped it out.
That's crazy.
That's why if you want to see,
if you want to see great Chinese art,
you have to go to Taiwan.
Because when the Chinese nationalists
left in 1949 when they lost,
as they were losing the civil war,
they took the treasures and they put
them in the National Museum of Taiwan in
the cultural revolution,
the great leap forward,
kind of the red guards were just
smashing all of their own stuff,
their own ancient history. Now, now the
Chinese Communist Party is saying, oh no,
we're going back and we have this
great 5,000 year old culture.
And some ways it's true,
but in some ways it's like an adolescent
culture without these kinds of
restrictions that other societies have
got such a unique perspective that I
haven't heard before.
And it makes so much sense in terms of
like how frantic they are restructuring
their world. Yeah. Yeah. And,
and they feel that they got screwed
over because there is this, this vague,
the sense of Chinese greatness.
When you hear the word middle kingdom,
it's like China, the center of
the world and everybody else,
some kind of of tributary.
And so their monumentally pissed off
that these colonial powers came and
overpowered them and they had
to make all these concessions.
They had to give land away and and hell
bent on regaining weight gaining and are
playing the long game.
They are playing a long game and we have
to be and we are not and we have to be
mindful of it. That's
also salty. You can do,
if you have complete
control of your population,
you don't have to worry about people's
opinions or you can just go in the
direction that you feel is
going to benefit the Chinese
power, the power that be,
wait,
this is a country run by engineers.
We per country run largely by lawyers
and and and reality TV people I guess.
Yeah,
but in China it's run by engineers.
So there are all these problems and
the answer is always engineering.
So if you have a population problem,
it's the answer is the one child
policy environmental problem.
You have Three Gorges Dam there. You
don't have water in the north of China.
You build this massive biggest water
project in the world from south to north.
You want to win in the Olympics,
you engineer your population,
you take kids away from their families
and put them in their Olympic sports
school.
So I write about this in Genesis Code.
If you're China and you kind of have
this Plato's republic model of the world
and work on to kind of identify the
genetic or maybe manipulate these genetic
superstars to be our greatest scientists
and mathematicians and business leaders
and political leaders like there a model
that you can imagine for for how to do
it. Wow. It makes you
really nervous. It should,
yes.
That's why like,
I just feel like with this country,
we don't have time to have all these
distractions that we're focusing on junk.
Like what it just like all of this,
you, I'm on CNN all the time when I'm,
when I'm home in New York and
I always say like you guys,
and I'm talking about kind
of geopolitical issues,
China and North Korea and when I always
say it's like you guys recognize this is
porn like CNN and Mspb.
That's like one kind of porn and Fox
and, and whoever else, info wars.
That's another kind of porn,
but it's all porn and we're just kind of,
we're drawing people's
attention to these few stories,
but there's these big stories
that we have to focus on. And,
and certainly the rise of China is such
an essential story for the 21st century
because China is competing in all
of these technologies. And China,
it's like go, go, go. I mean people in
China who were involved in the tech world,
when they go and visit silicon
valley uniformly, they say,
we cannot believe these
people are so lazy. Like,
why are they not working 24 hours a day?
Why are they not issuing product
new products every, uh, every week?
And so this is,
I mean,
they are racing somewhere and it's
going to have huge implications for the
world. And so if we believe in
our values as I believe we should,
we have to fight for them in the place
that we have to fight for him first is
here and we can't,
you know,
it's just like every day that we're
just focusing on this, this drama,
this reality TV drama of our
government is another day.
We're not focusing on the big things.
How are we going to get our act together?
How are we going to lead
the world and technology?
I mean another example
is this is immigration.
I think we have this whole fight
or how do we keep people out?
What I'd like to do is to go
to to the State Department.
I write every embassy in the world,
you have a new job. You have to,
we're going to give you whatever,
a number 500 slots per year.
You have to in your country find
the 500 most brilliant, talented,
creative, entrepreneurial people and
say, we're giving you a green card.
We're going to give you
a little starter money.
We want you to move to the United States
and just start a life and have kids and
if we we,
we should be creaming the crop,
skimming the cream over the rest of the
world. I think we could take over, we,
we could revitalize this country,
but we're having this fight of how do we
keep a small number of refugees out and
it's just we're not focusing on the
right things. That's a, that's again,
another very, very interesting
perspective. We are,
we learned about Huawei in this
country really. Not just, well,
I learned about it because they put
out some pretty innovative phones and
interesting technology,
but we learned it because
the State Department was
telling people to stop using
their phones. Yep. Do
you think that is trying
to stifle the competition?
Like to try to look good cause
the market share that they have,
if they do really have number the number
two selling cell phones in the world
now that's not from America. Americans
largely out of that conversation. Right.
And if they were in America,
they would probably dominate in America
as well because they're cheaper. Yeah.
And they're really good. Yeah. I mean
they're, they, they're phones are insane.
The cameras on their
phones are off the charts.
They put some video of the,
the zoom capability of their newest
phone and people were calling bullshit.
There's like,
there's no way that's not even possible.
But it turns out it was true. They
really can. It really can zoom. Yeah.
Like a super expensive telephoto Lens.
Yes.
Yeah. Yeah. So Huawei,
it's a complicated stew.
I for sure the founder of Walway is a
former Chinese military officer for sure.
Sure.
In the early stages of their company,
they stole straight out stole lots of
source code from companies like Cisco.
Um,
for sure we should be really worried
if Huawei is the sole supplier of the
infrastructure that supports 5g all
around the world because the Chinese
government would have
access to everything.
And so that leads us
to the question is one,
is there a problem with
Walway itself? Um, and,
but then two is let's just say,
and I inciting the answer to that
first question is probably yes. Um,
but then the question too is let's just
say who all way is a legit company and
they're not totally intimately
connected to the Chinese government.
Can we trust their relationship
with the Chinese government?
And the Chinese government has a rule
that every one of these companies has the
big Chinese national companies,
national champion companies,
they have a communist party
sell inside of that company.
And so these,
like,
I think that we can't think of big
Chinese companies just like we think of
companies here. We have to think
of them as quasi state actors.
And that's why this, this fight that's
happening right now is, is so important.
And that's why like when China is out
investing in different parts of the world,
including Africa,
their companies are kind of acting
like arms of the government.
They're making all kinds of investments
that don't really make sense.
If you just see,
well this is a company doing something.
If you say that this is a company with
backing by the state that's fulfilling a
function that supports the state, it's,
it's just, it's a very different model.
So I, I am actually quite
concerned about, uh,
about Huawei and I'm not a
fan of everything that this
administration is doing,
but I think on, on China, it's
important that we need to stand up.
And I think pushing back on Walway
is the right thing to do. I'm on to
about this for two reasons. One.
I'm uncomfortable about that,
about the Chinese government being
inexorably connected to this global
superpower in technology.
But I'm also uncomfortable that it's sets
a precedent for other nations follow.
Yeah.
Because
they're like,
look as the only way to compete,
because what you were talking about
the investments that Walway or that the
Chinese government makes
in these other countries,
and they don't seem to make sense if
you're just dealing with a company, right.
But if you're dealing with someone
who's trying to take over the world,
it makes a lot of sense.
And so when we have our companies that
you're out in someplace in Africa and
you're competing with a Chinese
company and to do something,
build a port or whatever,
and you're competing because you are an
American company and so you have your
cactus ideas, the poor, what's the
income stream going to be about it?
And you have a certain amount that you
can bid because otherwise it becomes a
bad investment. But if the Chinese
company is that their calculus is not,
is this a good or bad investment?
It's what is the state
interest in controlling or
quasi controlling this asset.
And so that's why we can't project
ourselves onto the Chinese.
We can't say they're just like us.
Just different.
We have different models and
our models are competing.
Do you think that we should avoid while
we products like consumer, should I,
well I think the government should very
tightly regulate products like a Walway
products because some of their
network routers or exactly,
they've shown that they, they're using
them to extract information. And so we've,
we have a long history of European,
Japanese,
half Korean companies that
have invested very well.
They've out competed us and we've,
we've allowed,
we allowed the Japanese companies to
outcompete our auto manufacturers.
And that was,
that was fine in the sense it are in the
1970s our cars had become shit because
we had this monopoly.
And so I'm all for open competition
and I'm all for free trade.
It has to be fair.
But I think that what China is doing,
China recognized as a state that they
could use the tools of capitalism to
achieve state ends. And I think we
need to be very cautious about that.
That's interesting that you'd compare
it to the automotive market because the
consequences are so much different.
Right. So much different cause,
but we do have a model to go on.
We could see what happened. We did,
we made shitty cars. The Japanese took
over and then we made better cars.
Like I have a rental car here. I'm in
Los Angeles. And I went to the, to the,
um,
the rental car place said at lax and
they had all of the different cars and
there was like a, a Nissan and
Toyota and there was a Cadillac.
And for the fact that, you know, I
said I'm going to go with the caddy.
So it's a great car, I think
are amazing. Incredible.
American cars are very good now.
They're great.
And then so like I'm all for competition,
but I just feel like what Chinese,
some Chinese companies are doing, it's
not competition. It's, they have become,
not all of them, but quasi state actors.
And if that's what they're doing,
I think we need to respond to
them in that way. Interesting. Um,
what else should we be concerned with,
which will be concerned with anything
that North Korea is doing? Oh, absolutely.
So I, I have, um, spent a lot of time
in North Korea. That's why I
brought it up. Yeah. So I've, um,
I advised the North Korea, North Korean
government and the establishment of,
of special economic zones,
which I certainly believe if North
Korea could have economic growth and
integrate into the rest of the world,
that would be great. And so I've, I, um,
when you went all this was in 2015
now, but I've been there twice. Um,
cross the border from China
and zigzag the country by land,
visited 10 or 12 different sites.
So spent almost two weeks by Lance.
I've really incredible.
I mean, North Korea, um,
one, it's the most organized
place I've ever seen. I mean,
there's not anywhere, there's
like on the side of the road, the,
the stones are all raked. There's not
a stick. Every little line is drawn.
It's like total control. There were
very, in the, in the agricultural areas,
there were very few machines
and very few farm animals.
So I saw people pulling
plows like you know,
usually have the animal in front of
the plow and the person behind here,
there were like two people in front of
the plow and one person behind the people
where the, the uh, the animals and we
would go and visit these. They just,
cause they didn't,
they,
a lot of the animals got eaten
when they had their famine.
And so we visited these different sites
for the special economic zones and they
would say like what they had done and
what they were thinking about doing.
And I would say like, how do you, do
you know anything about the market?
Like do you, what are you going
to sell here? And they said,
well we know about clearing land
and building a fence. And then we,
we went to Pyongyang and I spoke to
about 400 economic planners and I said,
look, I know you have these plans
that to the special economic zones,
it's totally going to fail
the way it's going to work.
You have to connect to the market economy.
You have to empower your workers,
you need information flow.
How else are you going to learn and adapt?
So North Korea,
it's a really dangerous place and
now it's even more dangerous because,
um,
president Trump threw it was this kind
of nonsensical hail Mary in these,
these meetings with Kim Jong Un,
there was no,
never any indication that the North
Koreans were planning on giving up their
nuclear weapons.
They never said they would.
It's the last thing they would do
it because their goal is survival.
And so there was this kind of head fake,
which was like a PR stunt to be able
to say, art, we're having these,
these meetings.
And of course the North Koreans weren't
ever going to give up their nuclear
weapons there. They're still not.
So now things are ramping up.
So North Korea in the last couple of
days has started firing missiles again at
the United States today and see us
military seized a North Korean ship.
So we're going back to
this very dangerous place.
And, and so I think we really
need to do a much better job.
We need much more concerned.
North Korea is,
it's really hard and these guys are
really smart. I mean, I, they are,
they are very, people say, well,
these guys are poor. They must not be,
I'm into like mad, like we're playing
cards with them. We've got the whole deck.
They don't have any one
card and yet they're there.
They're in the game.
They're holding us to a,
to a stalemate and it's really worrying.
And why did you go over there? Like what,
what,
what were you thinking?
So I thought a lot about it because
I have a background in human rights.
I was a human rights officer for
the United Nations in Cambodia.
I'm the child of a refugee.
I have this very strong belief in human
rights and that in supporting people in
North Korea,
they have about 120,000
people in the most brutal,
brutal,
horrific prison camps.
And so when I was asked to be part
of this six person delegation,
advising them on the special, on the
establishment of special economic zones,
one instinct was screw them.
I don't want to be part of this at all.
But I also felt that if North Korea could
have some kind of integrated economic
development that would at least
connect them to the world,
that would create some kind of leverage
and that would, uh, that would help, uh,
help people. So I decided, uh,
to go, um, and I'm glad that I,
that I did, but at this is, these are
really hard artichokes people. And,
and it's very unfortunate that in,
in president Trump's negotiations
with the North Koreans,
human rights was never once mentioned.
And I think that that's like,
as coming back to values,
like we have to be clear about who
we are and what we stand for and be
consistent in fighting for him.
Do you think that Trump didn't bring
that up because he wanted to be able to
effectively communicate with them
and not put them on their heels?
Maybe. Um, but I feel like
has, had they done, I mean,
I think that if he thought that
there was a real chance of progress,
but the hard thing was he didn't
know much about the North Koreans.
He has people and we have brilliant
people working in the United States
government and all of those people,
all of the US intelligence agencies were
telling president Trump that the North
Koreans have absolutely no intention
of giving up their nuclear weapons.
And so maybe he did think that he would
charm Kim Jong on, or he would say, hey,
we're gonna give you economic
development or, or whatever.
But I think for most people
who were observers of,
of Korea washed it for, I thought that
was not, uh, so we, we gave away a lot.
So we didn't mention human rights.
We suspended our military exercises.
We gave them the legitimacy
of a presidential meeting,
which they'd been wanting for 30 years,
and we didn't get anything back.
So it had we gotten something
back then you could say, well,
that was a risk for taking maybe. Mm. No,
I haven't heard it described that way,
but I'm agreeing with what you're saying.
What do you think he could
have done differently though?
I don't think the meeting should
have happened with, no, nope.
No conditions. There were no
police. So if he had said,
I'm open to meet with the North Koreans,
which is something the North
Koreans have always wanted,
we could have met with the North Koreans
anytime immediately for the last 30
years, but in order to do it they
need to do this, this and this.
And if they do it we'll meet like that
would have been a legitimate thing.
But what he said is somebody, the
the the North Korean, I'm inside the,
the South Korean national security
visors peeked into his office and he,
and he goes, hey, they wanted
me to, and it was like, sure,
that seems like an
interesting thing to do.
And I think that with this diplomacy
you kind of have to get something.
And so we gave away so much upfront
and the North Koreans weren't,
didn't have it an incentive to do anything
in return was his perspective that it
would be better to be in communication
and to be friends with this guy.
Who was that? What was that?
What he was thinking like B.
But we have real interests in the sense
that we have large military forces in
Seoul. We have a lot at stake.
We have our closest ally,
Japan who has had citizens abducted.
And so I think that was what he
thought is like, let's be friendly.
And then with the f the force of
personal chemistry, um, everything will,
will unlock. But I think that
was always extremely unlikely.
What do you think is going to happen
with our country? I think eventually,
and I've written this,
I think eventually this regime will,
will collapse under its own weight,
but it's really held out a long time
because you think of the collapse of the
Soviet Union, they had enough Soviet
Union. It had enough bullets to survive.
If they had said,
you know,
we're just going to shoot everybody at
the Berlin Wall and every dissenter,
they would still be, the North Korea has
essentially murdered millions of people.
So with famine and execution
and, and, and, and prison camps.
So I think they're going to stay
for a while, but eventually, um,
there will be leaders in North Korea who
will come to the conclusion that it's
safer to oppose the Kim family than
to wait for the Kim family to come.
And get you in that true tends to happen
in these kind of totalitarian systems
where there's so little trust. There's
so little loyalty. Jesus. Yeah.
What is there, what other
conditions like technologically,
like what was their infrastructure log?
So the general infrastructure
is absolutely terrible. I mean,
they have roads in the big cities that
are actually quite nice roads because
there's no cars. And so, um, but their
infrastructure is, is terrible. I mean,
all of their, their power supply,
they have brownouts blackouts,
uh, all the time at their
manufacturing is all being decimated.
So it's terrible.
But they have really focused their
energy on building these nuclear weapons
because they think that these nuclear
weapons give them leverage to do things
and to extract concessions
and to get, uh, to get a bid.
It's terrible infrastructure.
So do,
they don't have an internet, right?
But they have something similar,
but it only allows them access to
a few state run websites. Well,
average person doesn't
have access to the inner.
So the way it works is
it's all about loyalty.
So you need three or so generations of
loyalty to the Kim family to even set
foot in Pyongyang, the
capital. So really? Yes.
So it's not like you can kind
of move around or whatever.
It's like just to be in the capital,
like you have to have your loyalty
proven and so average person out in the
country, they don't have
access to much a of anything.
They have a little bit more
now than they did in the past.
And then for this relatively small
number of elites who are in largely in
Pyongyang and in the other
cities which are like there,
there's a ring of defense around
these cities and just to, to enter,
you have to have all of these checks.
Some of them have access to limited
internet. Um, but it's, it's,
it's tightly controlled and it's not
like you're kind of going on Google and
look going wherever you want.
And they probably would get in trouble
if the Gould the wrong thing. Yes.
And trouble. It's not just you
trouble like if you Chubb, if,
if my brother or my uncle does something
that gets me in trouble with the
regime,
the whole extended family is out.
And that means you either you go to
prison camps or you're kicked out of
Pyongyang.
I mean at this it's all about collective
punish and people are terrified.
And by that ruthless punishment
structure that they've set up,
that's how they've kept
control of the country.
And everybody's forced to
rat on each other, right?
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. Yeah.
They're,
they're,
they're actually the compelled to tell
on each other for one thing that you did.
If you don't, then what if you don't,
then you are complicit because they, yes.
So that's, and that's, they're
these horrible stories.
I've met a lot of these, uh,
of these people who were in the prison
camps. Like I have a, a friend of mine,
I mean, she was this 13 year old
girl and her father, um, was a,
like a low level North Korean official.
And then he was accused of something.
And so this family that was
privileged all of a sudden was,
was out and just just these horrible
things in prison and rape and this little,
I mean,
now she's in the United States and
incredibly positive and it's amazing how
resilient she is. But this is like a
real hell and it's a real, it's an issue.
And I think that for us as Americans,
as humans,
we're less human when there are people who
are suffering like this. Yeah, I agree.
Now, um, you were traveling
all over North Korea.
What were they having
you do while you were,
so we would do is we would go from one
of these special economic zones to the
other. And in each one it was kind
of the same story. You'd get there,
there'd be like a big field.
The farmers had been kicked off,
there was a fence around it.
And then the group of,
of the local officials would come and
they'd have like a big chart and they have
a plan.
Like,
here's where we're going to build
this building and here's [inaudible].
And I always ask the same question
like what are you going to do here?
Why do you think you're
going to be competitive?
How do you know what
the market prices are?
How are your workers going to be empowered
so they can change things? I mean, he,
in the old days, it used to be you just
kind of have these automaton workers.
Now workers are actually
making big decisions and
fixing things and they didn't
have an answer to any of those questions.
And that's what happens when you have
these totalitarian top down systems is
that like if, if you, being creative
is actually really dangerous.
So if somebody says do x, you
just do X. Wow. Yeah, no, it's,
it's really incredible and it's,
it's so sad because I spend a lot of
time in South Korea and this is the most
dynamic place.
There's like I often I go to soul just
to see what technology is going to show
up here a few years in the future.
I mean it's,
it Seoul is like the future and
then just 35 miles from soul is the
demilitarized zone. And the
other side it's, it's incredible.
And the real problem would be once they
finally did get free of that community
or the of that, that mean you
can call him whenever you want.
The dictator and that him and his family,
what would they,
what tools would they have?
Like how prepared would they be to be
autonomy? Well it's really the good thing,
the benefit that they have if there is,
so here's my thought of what a
scenario the scenario might look like.
And I think eventually probably there'll
be some kind of coup attempt against
the Kim Fam.
Let's just say it succeeds.
But that would probably result in another
military dictatorship with another
group.
Well we don't know cause then I think
immediately I think the Chinese would
invade. Really? Yeah. Cause
people think of the curb.
When people think of the Korean War
from the early 1950s they think,
oh it's the crane where it must've
been the Americans fighting against the
Koreans. But the Korean
War, the two sides,
where is America and the South Koreans
fighting against the North Koreans and
the Chinese, the Chinese did the most
of the, uh, of the, uh, of the fighting.
And so China and North Korea is the only
country in the world that has a treaty
alliance now with China,
kind of like we have with Japan and with,
and with South Korea.
And so China,
their biggest fear is having
a reunified Korean peninsula,
al allied to the United States.
So I think if there was a coup,
the Chinese would immediately
move in militarily.
Then immediately there would be this
call to have some kind of UN body.
Um, and there would be a
call for a UN authority.
And then I think it would be agreed that
the Chinese would stay and they just
would put on blue helmets,
like as a, as a UN force.
And then we'd have to
negotiate what happens next.
And I think what the Chinese
would do would be say, well,
we'll leave when the Americans leave,
is that,
I think that would be
what will likely happen.
But eventually I think we're going
to see a Korean reunification.
And the good news of these reunified
countries like eastern West Germany is,
there's a whole system of law
that he's just, he's just,
North Korea will be swallowed into
South Korea. And then you have law,
you have an infrastructure and it, it'll
take, you know, one or two generations,
but I think that will eventually happen
and I'm hoping it can happen without
nuclear war. Terrible.
A terrible bloodshed.
But it's that it's going to be
a big challenge. God Damn. Yeah.
That insurmountable.
Yeah.
Just hearing you talk about that.
What about North Korea getting absorbed
by South Korea? I'm like, oh my God,
good luck. Just, yeah, imagine.
Just imagine the whole thing.
Yeah. Well listen man, it's
been a fascinating conversation.
I really appreciate it everybody. I
really appreciate you coming here and um,
you've certainly sparked
a lot of interesting ideas
in my head and I'm sure a
lot of other people's heads as well.
And I would like to see a down the line,
where are the salt goes? And I hope
it don't get swallowed up by machines.
We won't, but it's up to us to
fight for what we believe in. Well,
thank you very much, man.
Really appreciate it. It was
a lot of fine. Bye everybody.
Okay.
Hmm
hmm.